oh no
oh it's a crazy day a lot of news
so this story comes out the other day
we've got uh Paul Pelosi's attacker is
is in court and his son gives an
interview claiming that his dad may have
been a sex slave I'm just going to come
out and say it I'm sorry I know you may
maybe have kids sitting around but
this is just where we're at I guess he
said his dad's hardly a right-wing
conservative but all of a sudden now his
dad's coming out saying he was
radicalized by gamergate or something
and I'm just I'm watching it and like I
don't believe any of it I don't believe
the story that the official narrative
he's a right-wing crate nut attacking
the Pelosi's and I don't believe he was
a sex slave but this story is just nuts
so we have to talk about it you know we
wanted to talk about a bunch of things
you got five antifa charged with felon
uh with domestic Terror in Georgia which
is huge you've got uh Elon Musk Twitter
is taking down far leftists so holy
smokes this one's Crazy Aaron RuPaul you
know you love him just got suspended we
don't know exactly what's going on yet
so we're gonna let that story stew hit a
little refresh in a few minutes and see
what the updates are but this is the
famous rupar where you take a story
Twisted out of context and then lie you
know ruparing he got suspended they also
suspended it's going down an antifa
account a lot of really interesting
stuff and then of course
Port Noy of Barstool Sports said that
Alex Stein should have been shot for
entering his office
okay I don't know about that but I also
said something similar if someone
stormed our building for very very
different reasons they might get shot so
we'll talk about that before we get
started my friends we have an awesome
sponsor head over to eat right and
feelwell.com to get your BioTrust keto
C8 MCT oil powder you may have noticed
if you look at the old videos from IRL I
was much more portly and I lost a lot of
weight doing keto cutting out the sugars
today I had like chicken and onions and
I love this keto oil powder this MCT
medium chain triglyceride stuff put it
in my coffee makes it very very creamy
and delicious so go to EatRight and
feelwell.com you'll get 51 off today
you'll get 60 days money back guarantee
it provides your body only C8 the most
ketogenic medium chain triglyceride
providing support for energy levels
healthy appetite Management Mental
Clarity and focus
5 grams per scoop personally it's my
favorite and you know they want me to
say that but it is true because we had
someone who brought a different kind
before and I was like it's not really
that good this stuff is like it's really
good it's like you put in your coffee
and it makes it creamy you get free
shipping on every order and for every
order today bio trust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor to their partnership with no
kidhungry.org to date BioTrust has
provided over 5 million meals to Hungry
kids please help them hit their goals of
six million meals this year you'll get
free VIP live health and fitness
coaching from BioTrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order so again eat right and
feelwell.com Shout Out BioTrust thanks
for sponsoring the show also head over
to timcast.com become a member join us
click that join us button you'll get
access to our members only uncensored
show which will be coming up tonight we
do those Monday through Thursday there
is a massive library of uncensored
interviews on a variety of subjects that
you can check out when you become a
member plus all of our other shows we
got big news too I'm hoping that with
the launch of our first cafe coffee shop
Community hangout I'm hoping by this
time next year we'll have I want to say
10 but let's say four I'm hoping that we
can set up these hubs these these places
where you can grab a cup of coffee hang
out read a book watch a show and just
start creating physical spaces in
various places so I'm really excited for
that so don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends joining us
today to talk about all this and more is
Michael Knowles
Tim it's great to be with you man thanks
so much excuse me he's called me not
Michael his name's me please please may
may yeah sorry got The Branding wrong
May well thank you for having me though
it's really good I I am excited to talk
about the Paul Pelosi story I was not
able to read the story uh I was not able
to read almost anything today but I'll
look forward to talking about hearing
what you guys you also wanted to talk
about who they are that run the daily
wire that's true I do I do know them two
Protestants one of them but one of them
is yeah one of them oh throwback jokes
uh so Michael Knowles thanks thanks for
hanging out it's really great to be here
too I I take it you're somewhere in this
direction yeah I am that's right yeah
you mentioned so you're opening up a
coffee shop yeah we got the building
it's uh it's in it's in uh in process
right now you think it would be a good
place to for people to go and like read
books and stuff uh yeah well if if you
want oh no I could I could I could
donate for your coffee shop it's a great
book pretty sure you gave us a signed
copy already so well well that's for
your house this one though this is a
speechless controlling where it's
controlling that's right it's available
right now this table is actually very
big is it signed uh it's not actually
not yet but I can once I can see again
maybe I'll uh people think the room's
actually really small this table is is
what is it I think it's like 12 no it's
like 16 feet by four and a half feet or
something like that
it's a very very massive it's big it's a
big one all right Michael thanks for
hanging out with your [ __ ] mask and uh
Luke's here too it's a Balenciaga mask
please Tim get it right me I apologize
for this unprofessionalism thank you I
will tell you by the way this is it's
not a Balenciaga mask because I I felt I
I didn't want to give money to the uh
satanic pedophiles so this is this is
there's also the Balenciaga one's very
expensive this one's like four bucks on
Amazon yeah Valencia is like 400 bucks
yeah about that anyway my name is we are
change.org I have one simple message
today and that is homeschool your kids
that's why today I have a shirt that
reads kids don't belong in
indoctrination systems and if you like
the shirt that I'm wearing and you want
to support me the best way you could do
that is by getting the shirt you could
get it on the best politicalshirts.com
because you guys do that's why I'm here
thank you again so much for having me
bye everybody it's me oh well you're
welcome me e dude Knowles you're the guy
with the name the last name is the most
like the word knowledge wow I've never
thought about that that's very fitting
that's got to be symbolic a coin I would
imagine it's just a coincidence it's
also the same last name as Beyonce I I
got to be honest though your last name
is no less
um
you and every Twitter troll I've ever
had what they do is that what they say
they say oh you got me now John 6 3 7 5.
I'm very excited you're here Michael I
know we're going to talk about the news
maybe we can talk about Judaism and
Christianity a little bit at some point
I think there's some sort of Confluence
going on and it's in the air and you
know a lot about it so I'd love to pick
your brand sure sure and um we'll go
deeper then hi uh what's up everybody
I'm pushing buttons it is Kellen uh
let's get this show started Yeah we
actually had to uh deploy surge to
Arizona because we're going to be at
Turning Point USA on Monday doing the
whole show on stage with uh rotating
panel of guests and I can only imagine
it's going to get crazy and silly and
I'm like I'm not I can't say with the
guests are just yet because we don't
like to but I'm like oh we're getting
banned they're pretty big guests they're
gonna get us in trouble so but it's
worth it we're going for it multi-stream
to multiple networks for this one no I
don't know I'm gonna do a show like
normal but we'll be on stage with 10 000
people and then we're gonna have great
guests come in who are going to say
spicy things we'll have a backup ready
I'm so glad I wonder if people will yell
out shut up Ian you think they will
because they say it in the chat that's
gonna be less I'm gonna be because I'm
also going to TV USA and I'll be in that
like the third row back just shut up Ian
I'll make eye contact I'm gonna organize
a chant don't worry all right let's get
into it so this story is from uh the
other day but it's just it's too much
quote for all we know he was some sort
of sex slave son of Paul Pelosi's
alleged attacker says his father is not
evil believes in human rights and is
hardly a right-wing conservative
so he said quote he isn't a danger to
society I don't even know if he even
attacked Mr Pelosi for all that we know
he was some sort of sex slave as Elon
Musk pointed out and then when I read
that I just
we had a conversation about this on the
show specifically saying hey he was
probably tied down hey Paul Pelosi was
probably doing really bad things to him
we were saying the same exact things
that his son is saying right now but
maybe his son is saying it because and
and and I'll clarify
I think that was you saying yes I did
yeah yeah I'm pretty sure Tim said it I
heard that don't point the finger at me
I said don't give up I said don't give
him any any benefit of the doubt let's
let's go off with the craziest things
and let's say that's a possibility here
because of the absence of evidence
because they're hiding so much
information because they're changing
their story time and time again because
they're they're suspending the NBC
reporters
who still hasn't come back to work yeah
he's still punished because he reported
on what police officers were telling him
actually happened on that particular day
so when you have very rich powerful
people you'd never give them the benefit
of the doubt we shouldn't hear and what
his son says I mean it's important to
pay attention to he also goes on talked
about how his father the person accused
here believes in equality Justice how he
was an activist against the war how he
was a peace activist he was quote hardly
a right-wing conservative both when we
look at the media they've framed this
entire attack as we need to go after all
the conspiracy theorists these
conspiracy theorists are dangerous these
conservatives are dangerous we need to
stop them right now that's the narrative
that they were going with that that's
the agenda that they were going with and
it failed right on its face I think the
conservative mention is what really is
like a red light to me that they
mentioned and call him a right-wing
activist is like it puts everything else
into question about the story not that
it should because maybe they're just
picking one thing and but he's obviously
like a green party the other way you
know that there's a lot more going on
here is that the story just disappeared
immediately right because what they told
us was that uh that the Speaker of the
House of Representatives had her home
invaded so that someone could murder her
so if that if that actually happened
it just seems to me like the sort of
thing that we ought to be talking about
a little bit more but then when these
details came out like when NBC reported
that Paul Pelosi himself opened the door
did not seem to be in distress walked
back to his alleged attacker when it
came out that this this attacker
actually wasn't some right winger he was
living on some weird sort of rainbow
colored commune type thing when all of
these when you heard the dispatch phone
call then all of a sudden the story just
completely went away yep just like just
like Club Q just like the Las Vegas
shooting just like so many other large
events that we somehow don't want to
talk about now very conveniently they
just sell tickets I mean there's just
it's possible a lot of the stuff they
claim because there's no video they have
a story that works uh towards their
benefit that they're going to use and
emotionally exploit in order to push for
a certain agenda once those version of
events are different they don't have
their conclusion that they conveniently
came up with as soon as the event
happened right away
so sorry I just want to explain what
happened well they're they're trying to
drive a cultural shift a narrative and
when they can't they can't and they stop
for re for record I mean I believe the
Pelosi's when they're not home they have
security at the house even when they're
not there they're one of the richest
people in the world to think that they
don't have Securities is absolutely
crazy no no but think about this too
look at what's going on with Elon some
dude attacked his kid yeah and he posted
the video about it for obvious reasons
elon's got crazy security you think the
Pelosi's after especially with their
hype of January 6 they didn't have
security or something they've got to I
mean Pelosi was calling for machine guns
at the Capitol literally every single
semi-buji Millennial has
so many camera security systems around
us I'm constantly recording on their
phones all the time anybody who is at
all in political prominence has heavy
security if not 24 7 home security
you're telling me that the person third
in line to the U.S presidency just
Whoopsie Daisy didn't have any cameras
and didn't have any I just absurd can I
I want to point this out too the New
York Times Reporter the other day quote
how did I get into all of this Mr depap
wrote in one passage on his blog
gamergate it was gamergate I love that
because nobody who actually knew
anything about gamergate would come out
and be like I was radicalized by
gamergate like that's just not a way
that sounds like something who is not
paying attention to the culture War it
sounds like something they would say to
make you like they think they're
convincing you right
um it's like it's like a patriot front
right yeah you kind of you say you know
I was radicalized by the Q a non-gamer
gate insurrectionist Patriot front is
that yeah hey Quantico is that what I
was supposed to say okay good got it is
gamergate when the Communist man
basically slid into the American
Zeitgeist was gamergate was at the first
moment where we start to see this like
social this weird social movement
gamergate was like some chick slept with
some guy in exchange for a positive
review of her game yeah
right right
so
somehow it turned into
what happens is you get a lot of people
then pointing out that these woke
journalists are writing this fake
wokeness stuff and it becomes somewhat
culture worry like it does elevate to
that point but like the initial issue of
gamergate this makes no sense yeah it's
like somebody who read a Wikipedia entry
about the culture war is trying to
convince you that they were a part of it
from the beginning no the weirdest thing
about this is if the if the guy's Kids
come out and say he's not a conservative
he's a green party guy but this guy is
going into court and saying that he was
going to Target Tom Hanks and Gavin
Newsom I don't believe him like it's
here's the funny thing this guy goes to
court and makes these claims about
gamergate or whatever he hasn't a Blog I
think not he's making the claims but
apparently he had a list I'm like you
expect me to believe the guy who you
claim attacked Paul Pelosi he sounds
crazy I'm sorry I'm not going to believe
this I think this is a key here too
because people are trying to construct
really sophisticated narratives about
what's going on but is it not possible I
humbly propose that this guy is kind of
crazy he's like a crazy guy I think
that's possible yeah see that's one
explanation I I have a different
explanation and it goes kind of further
down the rabbit hole to say the least
and I think it should go down the rabbit
hole especially with how powerful how
Sinister how absolutely evil The Core
Power inside of the United States really
is especially with all the private
islands that they go to we and we only
are scratching up the surface to the
true reality of what's Happening behind
the scenes there so I never give them
the benefit benefit of the doubt let's
just speculate here okay he was a sex
slave he was picked off off the street
he was living in a van he was going to
be sacrificed he was going to be
tortured he was going to be forced on by
Paul Pelosi because I'm doing what the
corporate media is doing the corporate
media did that as soon as the story
broke they said we have in the narrative
who we know exactly what happened he did
it because he hated him because he was a
right winger they're doing it I'm gonna
do it my way and I'll bet my bottom
dollar right now my weight's probably a
lot more correct than they are I got it
we should do a skit called like you know
uh it should be called something we'll
call it captive the depap story and it's
like a guy's kidnapped and dragged into
this house and it'll be like that scene
from Pulp Fiction you know you guys know
where I'm going with this I'm kidding
look my view of this is The Simple
Solution is it's a crazy guy you know
what I mean I understand your point
though Luke don't give them go don't
give them the benefit of the doubt if
they're not going to release the video
so we can see what happens in a world
where creepypeto Island exists and in a
world where everything I know we're on
YouTube so I'll be really super careful
where
um every single thing we've been told by
anyone in Authority for the past two and
a half years is totally fake uh in a
world then then in in that world it is
reasonable it is more reasonable to
assume that Paul and Nancy Pelosi every
single night are whipping and torturing
this random guy than it is to believe
the CNN thank you absolutely and they
also have the Bohemian growth you know
what they do with the bihime and go mock
child sacrifices to molec as they walk
around naked in the woods that's
literally what happens and it's
documented so you know you're forcing me
to disagree but I only disagree a little
because I agree with the the the points
both of you make why are we going to
trust the New York Times or CNN after
everything they've lied about so I would
I would put it this way I am willing to
say fine this guy's kid says for all we
know he was a sex slave and they need to
produce the evidence to produce to prove
otherwise now in all sincerity I think
this guy's probably just a crazy person
yeah and I think if there was a story
that made sense outside of the official
narrative or the conspiracy theory drug
deal gone wrong yeah his son I think
said the David the pap son said that
David was like abused growing up I think
he lived with his grandparents and they
were real abusive so he would spend his
days away from home at the ocean just
like waiting for them to be asleep by
the time he gets home a messed up guy
like messed up in his childhood kind of
guy uh most same people don't like jump
at the opportunity to go deal drugs to a
politician or
politician the most 10 people would not
would not want to spend any time near
the Pelosi it's too dangerous I mean
just for your own livelihood to get
involved with it let's just break
something down real quick right
I just want I don't want to believe
anything I want proof and so I'm willing
to say your official narrative in the
courts is total bunk BS because you've
not explained anything properly or given
us video footage but to me if I was
gonna if I'm looking at a roulette wheel
with a bunch of different outcomes for
the story and I got to put my chips down
I'm putting it on why aren't there why
isn't there footage of it Paul turned
the cameras off because he was buying
drugs where are the security guards Paul
told him to go take a walk because his
drug dealers showing up if I went to you
and said do you think prominent people
are doing drugs
like everyone says yes to that but
couldn't I my only problem with that
theory is couldn't a Pelosi get a posh
or drug dealer you know when I I think
of my friends in New York and La over
the years who've who have been
pharmaceutical you know they always go
to some like Rich fancy guy maybe but
think about this too the guy was a green
party leftist right yeah so if if you're
someone like Pelosi and you need
discretion you also want to make sure
you've got someone who's not going to go
it's Paul Pelosi can throw under the bus
later not so much that but someone that
is less likely like I'm not going to
invite a GrubHub driver over here who's
got an antifa profile you know what I
mean we don't want to let someone of
those ideas we want to make sure that so
for the most part we're not really
worried about deliveries I'm just saying
right I I'm not saying it's it's true or
guaranteed I'm just saying I lean
towards I bet dude called up his connect
and said you know he wanted Coke or
something told the security guard say
take a walk that's why there's no
security there the reason why he told
the cops I don't know who he is but he's
a friend is because he invited him over
but was not familiar with who he was the
reason why he answers the door politely
and says we're taking care of it is
because he doesn't want things to get
out you know I just I kind of feel like
dude was buying drugs Michael though
these people have handlers these people
have Associates these people got got
people that do everything for them at
the snap of a finger if you tell a
Handler hey go get me this they'll go
get it so that's the people that they
have in Washington DC why wouldn't they
have it in San Francisco to me again why
are we speculating we shouldn't be
speculating we should be calling for
more evidence we shouldn't be giving
them the benefit of the doubt if we're
going to be having a conversation here
worst possible scenario always
um and that that's I think you know
what's going to happen we're not going
to find out any more information the
story is just going to disappear because
it doesn't serve their narrative and
it's really weird and it raises a lot of
questions about them but they they wrote
a hit piece about us because we were
talking about this subject you know a
week or so ago or two weeks ago the
leftist media machine starts writing you
know Tim cast IRL pushing insane
conspiracies and it's I'm sorry guys in
the media if you don't have anything to
actually say you can't say anything
about us if if if you're like we have no
evidence we have no idea what happens
but it's it's whatever the government
said it doesn't fly and I don't care
what you think no it's too it's too
dangerous to make claims about what
happened this guy's life's on the line
right now David to Pap like he could go
away to prison for the rest of his life
this guy's about they're about to they
want to just put it all on him I mean In
fairness though three Hots in a cot
might not be the worst thing for this
guy like he was not living a flourishing
lifestyle beforehand so David de pop did
not Epstein himself I'm calling it here
where's his phone I want to see the
records is he texting yeah you know
before texting uh what's his name what's
what's Pelosi Paul's Paul's phone and
Paul by the way made a spectacular
recovery apparent looking he seems to
have I saw a picture of him and Nancy
and he looks fine we also have to
realize we're dealing with people that
uh suspend journalists at end NBC News
and make them not come back to their
work okay that's how powerful these
people are and you know but by the way
you're telling me they're telling the
truth here the way that's being covered
is oh NBC made a mistake and then they
edited it
this wasn't like a typo in an article
there was a fully fleshed out several
minutes-long TV News segment where an
investigative journalist went in and
covered Moment by moment what happened
and then with no explanation whatsoever
NBC just pulled the record at another
media organization yeah yeah and another
media organization covered it as well
did the same reporting based off police
sources that NBC reporter he wasn't
making things up he wasn't speculating
he was like I talked to this police
officer and this police officer and I
saw this police report he was
documenting what actually was being
reported so I guess we'll just rare in
journalism we'll we'll see how this
plays out in court I guess otherwise you
know we have no idea but I want to jump
to this next story because this one
makes me uh it gives me a hearty Turtle
John Levine reports reporters covering
Elon Musk being nuked Dania Sullivan for
CNN Drew Harwell for Washington Post
Ryan Mack the New York Times and Aaron
rupar independent all gone awesome the
gun take a look at this so uh Libs of
tick tock says Taylor Lorenz just scrub
her entire Twitter account what Oh Me Oh
My times they are a changing love it
prominent liberal journalist Aaron rupar
suspended by Twitter for those that
aren't familiar with uh Aaron rupar
there's a verb it's called ruparing or
to rupar and it's when you take an out
of context clip and apply false context
to manipulate people that is ruparing so
uh he got nuked and I think we have a
tweet here yasher Ali says Aaron rubar
tells me he has not received any
correspondence from Twitter and does not
know why his account is suspended I
believe rupar is the guy that sued
didn't he sue the previous Twitter
Administration to get his account back I
might think of a difference someone else
they would never suspend that guy I'm
wondering if the reason they got
suspended was for posting something
pertaining to his location I don't know
for sure but Elon just the other day
posted a video of a guy who attacked his
his family his kid who looked who looked
like an antifa guy yup he was dressed
like one yeah conservatives don't do
that conservative guy in fact I gotta be
honest I put out that tweet where I was
like Nora link was I used to think it
was scary and dangerous but then Elon
agreed with me ideologically now I like
it like I got I I'd be willing to bet
anyone on the right who's crazy enough
to track down musk would be like we love
you Elon of course keep it up yeah you
always got false Flags can never truly
judge a book by its cover like
speechless that's true
in car so like that's the one Wrinkle in
the in the argument here some kind of
wealth asset but it's great I don't I
don't care at all so you know I don't
want to hear this well you know where we
thought Elon was going to be the free
speech absolutist and now he's
suspending no I I didn't I don't know
I'm not a free speech absolutist I I
believe in standards and norms and you
know what I really believe in banning
these left-wing losers and I really
believe especially Banning that guy who
was tracking elon's plane that guy's
gone but the rest of them too I see
absolutely no reason for Elon Musk to
tolerate them remaining on Twitter how
do you define free speech well I Define
Free Speech as uh the I Define free
speech I suppose as the founding fathers
might have defined Free Speech which is
or even as John Locke the father of
liberalism might have defined Free
Speech which is not totally free which
is yes we have broad Toleration for lots
of different things but there are limits
and they're pretty severe limits I mean
let's not forget we're not only talking
about speech acts like fraud or direct
threats or obscenity or things like that
people a lot of people don't even think
of obscenity these days as something not
protected by Free Speech but I would go
further than that all right yes it's
true that the libs have speech codes but
chivalry is a speech code too you know
and I'm all for chivalry I'm all for
Banning people who who are degrading our
society I mean you know just as a matter
of historical fact
speech earlier on in American history
was much more restricted in certain ways
than than it is right now we had a
blasphemy laws for much of America and
obscenity we still have obscenity laws
on the books they just don't enforce
them now in fact now they only enforce
it if you have wholesome speech if you
if you speak obscenely then you get to
do it that's why I say culture is more
important because we got a ton of laws
on the books they started ignoring
personally I I disagree because who who
do you decide who's degrading Society
with what ideas I think if there's bad
with your reason and your moral
conscience yeah but who's going to be
calling the shots here I think the
people who aren't here exactly and power
uh corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely but when it comes to bad
ideas they need to be challenged with
good ideas I think we need open debate I
think we need open conversation and I'm
very curious to see what happened here
and I'm more skeptical because I believe
at the end of the day even though we
might might not agree with each other I
still rather have that conversation
rather than say I just only want to hear
myself do we need to have a conversation
about the virtues of child pornography
do we need to have that debate that's a
debate we really need to have that is
one issue that obviously I I stand with
with you on uh but I know you're
obviously you stand with me on yeah
child pornography obviously do you think
we need to have the debate you know in
the free Marketplace I don't think we do
if there's idiots out there right who do
believe in concerned which there is
right
they didn't they they deserve to be
challenged they deserve to be pushed
back they deserve it because because but
again
um if you push people away just like you
do with the censorship that's been
happening you push people to more
radicalized corners of the internet and
they double down on that on their ideas
rather than having a whole bunch of
people telling them hey this is wrong
and not acceptable here by pushing them
away they won't have that kind of
pushback in their life and they're like
okay I'm just gonna hang around other
you know CD people and think this is
okay when it's not I I I actually would
agree with you Michael on this one I I
see Luke's point but I think it can be
refined like there's a reason why we
publicly denounce the reason why you're
saying right now we don't need to have a
debate it's settled we figured it out
yeah but that's one issue but that in
all the issues no for sure and that
means that there will come a time when
you need to explain to someone who maybe
says well people should be allowed to
have their opinions and you can be like
look there are some things that are so
morally reprehensible that it's
universally despised in among most human
beings and you know we will tell you why
it's bad
I mean this this was William F Buckley
Jr who was who's credited as the founder
of the mainstream post-war conservative
movement as Urbane and open-minded a
fellow as ever there was he he had a
debate on his show with a
neoconservative uh Leo churn and chern
said we need to have the open society
and the free Marketplace of ideas and
Bill Buckley said you know I actually
think we can close Society off a little
bit yes we discussed lots of things but
he said I'm an epistemological optimist
I think that certain things are settled
and we don't really need to entertain
Nazis or Communists your political
opponents are doing the same exact thing
you're doing in Europe arresting people
for saying that men can't be lesbians
they're using the same justifications
and arguments you are and this is
using the same procedures but the
substance of what they are doing is the
opposite they're saying I know what's
best for society I know what ideas are
good or bad right you have to stop these
ideas we have to stop right-wing ideas
but there's therefore if you there hurt
people with your idea is we have to stop
you censor you and throw you into look
the difference is that there's there's a
difference between good and bad so when
I if I'm the CEO of Twitter and I'm
determining what the standards and Norms
are on Twitter and I encourage good true
and beautiful things and I discourage
ugly false and wicked things that's not
the same thing as what the libs do but
that's based off your interpretation
because for them what's beautiful
right that's beautiful for them but Luca
that's your interpretation but they're
wrong is the is the thing and so we have
faculties of reason and moral conscience
and we can perceive the world and come
to Fairly reliable conclusions let me
let me just make a point here uh we like
to believe that the law is that the
world is logical that we can set forth a
set of rules that say you cannot do X Y
and Z and then what we discover is the
interpretations of X Y and Z vary wildly
and we actually struggle to to operate
at humans struggle to operate on a moral
logical level in that if you come out
and say you know don't don't be mean
don't be bad don't hurt somebody and
then someone says okay well insulting
you is my opinion I'm not hurting and
then someone else interprets it as
hurting we see there's an issue there my
view is I air towards mostly free speech
I agree with you on things like child
porn I think there's probably things we
can say Do not advocate for something
like that right yeah if you're
advocating for that on the platform form
we can restrict you or shut you down or
something like this the issue is and
I'll throw it back to the law
we have a bunch of laws on the books
legally you cannot do but they don't
enforce anymore because our culture
changed which means there is a
centralized morality that human that
societies are willing to tolerate that
means we don't tolerate advocacy for
child porn and there's no reason to open
up tolerance to it we just don't
tolerate it well increasingly I guess
and that's and that's the issue so my
pushback for you a little bit is there
will be a debate whether you want it or
not because people will start pushing
but I suppose the the conservative view
from the past 20 years is politics is
Downstream of culture so stop passing
laws it's really just a libertarian view
but it's not passing laws and just you
know I don't know make you know make
better music or something and I'm not
I'm not really mocking it obviously the
culture matters a great deal but you
can't neatly separate these things and
the law is a teacher so if I'm looking
at how we got to this insane cultural
position now where we will be debating
the the virtues of child pornography and
pedos so it's already happening it's
happening they're accusing anybody who
criticizes actual pedophiles they go why
are you talking about gay people but we
got here you just but we got here
of censorship because of people say
this no no
no those ideas haven't been able to be
challenged because people have been
censored for going against them people
have been arrested for going against why
when when we had a a more uh sensor
sensor-minded regime uh that censored
bad things and promoted good things as
opposed to what we have now which is the
censorship regime that promotes bad
things and suppresses good things like
what's an example what do you mean well
I would say uh let's say the Pilgrims
land to Plymouth Rock in 1620 and then
from 1620 up through the founding of The
American Nation up through about I don't
know the early 60s we had a basic
consensus on what is moral and what is
immoral and it was it was Christianity
it was based on the Christian moral View
and then in the 1960s you saw led by the
government led by Supreme Court
decisions led by laws that that weakened
some of the uh censorship regime you saw
the uh you know attacks on McCarthyism
in the house on American activity
committee you saw the Free Speech
movement at Berkeley that led to to a
weakening of our obscenity laws you you
saw a weakening of our laws prescribing
certain sexual behaviors that then led
to the sexual Revolution when you opened
up that Society much more what happened
did it lead to this wonderful period of
flourishing no the society has gone
downhill it's gone straight to pot ever
since but but the parent the dads used
to beat the moms relentlessly that was
like they just didn't talk about it did
that happen I mean honorary like talked
about he would smack women around and
this was on TV and Society bad men beat
their wives today and so you know it
just seems to me what you're suggesting
is this very Progressive view that the
past was terrible for the presence
before we had the conversation good
people beat their wives it was it was
just accepted now that we're able to
have I don't think that's true I don't
think that I mean I don't think it's the
dawn of man the guy is like fall in line
or face the consequences but is your is
your argument in that in the past you
know the past was basically made up of
these knuckle dragging troglodyte men
abusing their wives and ever since we
had the sexual Revolution now
that doesn't happen that just seems like
a very Progressive Fantastical point I
think it was the internet or it was
really television and radio that that
broke the censorship mode whether we we
wanted it or not the technology made us
look at ourselves and be like that's
what we are we need to deal with this
but that's not cool but just really
quick deciding what's good and deciding
what's bad is arbitrary Depends for who
Depends for what Society
because at the end of the day the
government's sitting there and saying
you know Dr fauci's there and he's like
you know at the end of the day it's good
for a society if we censor all these
other signs and we let our Doctrine
through so therefore we need to censor
this speech we need to limit Free Speech
we need to ban accounts and essentially
that's what I see you calling for so so
here's here's where I see where we're at
uh I I air towards Free Speech allow
people to express their political views
to to be debated but I think there's a
little bit more limits than many of the
anarchists and Libertarians would be
willing to entertain and the reason I've
come to this position where I used to
just be alive well maybe you can say
whatever you want is because the system
as it's being laid out right now by you
and your view Luke allows the left to
say whatever they want while weaponizing
that to silence anyone who opposes them
meanwhile you're standing there saying
well they're allowed to do it I guess
I'm banned and they're not absolutely
crazy the idea of banning speech is what
created this exact society and that's
why these larger virtues and ideas need
to be pushed things they are cheating of
course they're playing fair and you're
losing because of it also Luke what
Society doesn't have taboos in what
Society is everything perfectly open I
mean that's never existed on Earth
anywhere I agree yeah you're right about
that but that doesn't so they are but
that doesn't mean that doesn't mean we
shouldn't strive towards towards
something that's impossible no no
towards respecting speech and debating
ideas let's bring this back to the to
the core story right the issue is Elon
Musk choosing to ban who he wants and my
position because I think this might
argument just go forever but I think if
we can bring this back to the story Elon
Musk needs to set clearly Define
parameters for what he wants but then we
also need judges to interpret in in the
United States we have laws but laws can
be challenged and judges interpret the
law so when a court when a legislative
body says you can't do X someone says
well hold on X could also include Y and
then a judge says good question I'll
give you my ruling tomorrow the judge
then look at the law looks at the
precedent hears the arguments and then
issues his judgment the law is not just
uh if if yes then you know if one then
why if two then it is it is humans
trying their best to interpret uh the
easiest way to put it is analog it's not
digital it's a wave not a point great
which means that that means we want it
to be there's free speech we respect
this but then when you actually start
looking into it you're like oh hold on
now we're getting into the advocacy for
child porn part from the left at a
certain point where like it may not be a
call for violence
but are we going to tolerate what a
level of advocacy that analogy it's the
it's the analog not the digital it's not
just the law is not just uh you know a
bunch of letters that self-interpret on
a sheet of paper but it involves a human
aspect and what this raises this
interpretive question bring I think
undercuts what you're saying about good
and bad because you you said that good
and bad are just arbitrary but you don't
believe that nobody believes it depends
on who decides it and it depends let me
ask you one question is it is it better
to cook a pie for a widow than it is
good you have to eat cilantro because I
decided so because I'm empowered that's
essentially what Luke just answer this
question is it is it better to cook a
pie for a widow or to kick a baby in the
head what kind of hypothetical question
are you even asking me it seems like a
simple one today like can you really not
answer that question like obviously
you're not going to be Supply made of
poison what's the context I'm not Paul
Pelosi here okay but it just shows the
absurdity of what you see we all know
that it's better even if she's allergic
it's still better to cook the pie for
the Widow than it is to kick the baby in
the head what's the pie made of is the
piece of lamb and mashed potatoes good
shepherd's pie you know like peas and
carrots but is it we all say that Mitch
pie is it a brother I don't even know
Marina
well that would be a bad pie but but
even the fact there are some Universal
truths obviously yes so good and bad or
not but when it comes to positions of
power that is usually blurred uh
obviously whenever you you give power
that power usually is being used against
other individuals so uh when we have
people who uh have a lot of
responsibility if you give them more
power and authority that's not checked
that's not counted especially when it
comes to speech it leads to very
tremendously horrible situations
throughout recorded human history and
when you give someone power to censor
criticism of themselves we have seen the
largest human atrocities because of that
but again this is a debate that's kind
of sidetracking our conversation we can
agree to disagree I respect your your
opinions I think you made some good
points as well and and uh and I think
this is an idea maybe we could even
debate afterwards because I know we
still got a crap ton of stories I want
to talk about the bar stool stuff but
I'll just reiterate on the right because
maybe we'll talk in the members only
we'll go nuts with it I just I I want to
believe in free speech I want to say
make your points and we'll argue it but
then I also recognize we we live in a
world of cultural morality we grew up we
have the roots of our parents we have
the Legacy the things that work to make
Humanities uh survive we've retained and
we've shaved off the bat over a long
period of time look slavery is not
acceptable anymore humans used it for a
long time the the better Parts have
stayed with us
I'd like to believe that we can write
down you know if a then B if x then y
but humans just don't operate that way I
mean Humanity thought slavery in the
Holocaust was a great idea they went
along with it right now but then it was
challenged and because it was challenged
because people said hey this is not okay
hey this is wrong I was challenged with
bombs right and by force so but it
started with speech and people and that
that's where it began World War II the
the Allied front in World War II did not
begin with speech it began with
airplanes and guns no no no obviously
there was Weaponry but obviously what
led up to it was a bunch of meetings
which a much of talks with a bunch of
escalations a bunch of things that were
related to trade were related to embargo
so it was a slow Chamberlain smoke and
Churchill shot right the the reason the
left holds the position they do is their
argument is that Hitler uh was allowed
to hold his rallies and to indoctrinate
and to expand and he was not
sufficiently opposed and his his
rhetoric was winning people over because
of their desperation he was basically
exploiting their grievances to trick
them into the psychotic idea he was also
suppressing people he didn't agree with
he had control of the media not that
that's afterwards how did he rise to the
point where he could do that he
manipulated and exploited people's
emotions their grievances over over
World War one and and the the debt to
France things like that the poor economy
he gave them things they wanted and then
Twisted that into his insane grievance
it's also worth remembering because you
know everyone always makes World War II
comparisons because it's like the only
thing that anyone's ever so Stalin no
yeah but but you know the the thing
that's important to remember before we
get to down the rabbit hole of thinking
we live in you know the time in the
1930s or 20s or something Weimar Germany
was completely destroyed you know money
was worthless mothers and daughters were
were holding prostitution teams together
like that that degree of desperation is
uh is you know not akin to something
we're seeing now but the libs exploit
this and they say well you know we're
just always living in the lead-up to
Hitler
I really want to address this story we
got this tweet from Alex Stein 99 prime
time he says it was just a joke dude
stool Presidente it's not that serious
let me play for you what David Portnoy
said and uh there's some Nuance to this
discussion but uh this is Alex Stein and
his wife's uh his wife's boyfriend uh
stormed into the bar stool sports
headquarters here's what was said and
[ __ ] slap him in the face I don't
think that guy's been slapped yet so I'm
glad he got slapped
you you hear people being like oh they
should charge assault charge he should
have been shot if we had a gun effort a
ski mask in a deranged homeless man
trying to barge
yeah yeah right I think it's the actor
which is right craziest part Yeah Yeah
Bang Bang You're Dead it's all those all
those people who want that will be like
well if you come into my house I can
shoot you with my gun all right well if
you have two lunatics a guy wearing a
ski mask bang bang and Hey fat tub alarm
bang sorry you we told you to leave you
wouldn't they're all like you leave no
he didn't Danny was like pushing him
yeah so where are they based out of what
what city are they based on this is New
York or where are they at I think New
York City
I'm just gonna say first and foremost
Dave you are wrong because I'm sorry if
you're in New York City can someone fact
check real quick then you're wrong no if
you're in New York City you don't get to
say someone should be shot yeah
headquartered in NYC yeah if you're
doing but the show like that where they
actually don't record no I don't know if
you're doing a show in a city where you
constantly vote for and pay taxes and
support the stripping away of your right
to keep in bear arms you don't get to
say someone who entered a public office
should be shot yeah now that being said
we here in Western Maryland and West
Virginia with castle doctrine and active
threats against us and armed guards I
will say there's a big difference if
someone stormed through first of all you
got to enter a large property you have
have to go past physical barricade
saying do not enter you are being warned
you will be shot then if somebody broke
in here I'd be like yeah you'd probably
get shot I don't want you to get shot I
don't think you should be you probably
will be because we're not going to try
and figure out your intention when you
break in but to stress Alex Stein was
joking
I'm not a big fan of storming into the
podcast office you know causing a fight
and all that stuff in in a lot of
circumstances yeah he'd get beaten up
he'd get arrested all that stuff but I
just want to make sure I can point out
you can't say that when you're in New
York city so there's also a difference
in that how many times have you been
swatted how many times have people
actually yeah I mean is it really that
high yeah oh my God so it's like
obviously you know that that's a
different level I I don't think Dave
portnoy's getting swatted all that much
the libs kind of like him he plays this
Centrist character and so it just seems
a little over the top I get that Alex
Stein also is a little over the top but
I don't think blowing his brains out is
totally proportionate here you know I
mean the thing is they know who he is
they know like if Alex Stein shows up
you know you're being pranked by a
comedian with a comedian guy not saying
I agree with it but their office is also
open like I don't want to say it's open
to the public but you can just walk up
and enter it's like a building in a city
and so people are pointing out the fact
that he was able to walk up walk in the
building go through the door there's no
obstructions there's no signs or
anything well yeah guys you gotta get a
guard and put up a sign saying hey you
know private access only these things
won't happen yeah I think that him
saying it's a joke is a bit of a cop-out
I've been using the word cop out a
little bit too much lately but I think
it's not a joke jokes are words you tell
jokes you say them you if you're doing
something your actions that's something
that's a bit maybe it's a bit maybe it's
an act but it's not a joke can I I just
wanna I just want to point out too you
said he plays this interest but he's
like the the the the mirror verse
version of centrism from where we are
like he's he's a Centrist on all the
worst things
so like you know he talks about being
pro-choice but it's just because if he
knocks a girl up he doesn't want to deal
with it that's like the worst reason
you'd be pro-choice yeah that was the
argument he was making with Andrew Tate
right exactly Andrew Tates are you going
with him against this what what kind of
world are we living in and and when you
live in New York City and you pay taxes
in New York City you're paying for 15
plus minute uh response times not for
your right to defend yourself so if you
want to defend yourself uh obviously you
have a right to do that uh you know the
question's Blurred here I mean when
someone jumps on your property you know
what do you do I mean the jurisdiction
that he's in doesn't allow him to do
anything it's not even his property it
I'm willing to bet assuming that shell
was in New York I don't know where Alex
is basically well Alex Stein was in New
York City when he did this okay okay so
these buildings are multi-least right
the the so you're entering a building
owned by someone who's not Barstool
Barstool rents this space that's why
he's able to walk through the halls and
go in the elevator because it's a
community-owned thing now you come out
to West Virginia where we got 50 acres
of our property wrapped in a big old
fence that says do not enter we will
defend ourselves with lethal Force very
very different circumstance plus you
know you're in New York bro you can't
have guns so yeah I don't know what I I
think he just wants to be like he
shouldn't have come in here he should
have come in here and I'm like to a
degree I would say yeah you shouldn't
have but you're in a communal building
he's a prankster people can just come
and go as they please I agree it's
probably over the top isn't this awesome
but shooting someone and this is this is
a way that New Yorkers talk I say this
as a new Yorker myself you know it's
it's always the hypothetical in the past
uh you know what I would have done you
know what I would have done if I had
been there and I had seen that oh I
would have done it so bad when it's just
be this he's not gonna he would have sat
there like everybody else of course of
course I I think Alex's taunting Dave
he's been taunting him for like a month
and a half and Dave finally I mean he
went into his his office and made a loud
noise and smell I'm sure uh no not that
Alex smells bad but you're letting your
smell out you know your pheromones bro
uh and Dave really took the bait but him
saying that you should have been shot
Alex is a lot of people are going to
hear that and a lot of people are going
to think okay if a guy comes into my
office maybe I should be shooting them
so that's a very bad bad thing this is
why you do not kill Joker on people no
no look you just can't can't be a New
York City liberal guy yeah saying like I
should have no you wouldn't you'd vote
to ban guns come on you know what's
weird to me though about this is some
conservatives really like Dave Portnoy
and I can you know he he's not exactly
my flavor of conservatism but where did
the Bad Blood start with Stein and
Portnoy about a month and a half ago on
Twitter I think uh Alex it was real
minor to be like Dave you smell I don't
know what were the thumb tweets I wish
Alex was here to tell us I don't know no
it started with something specific that
really yeah but it was like a low-key it
wasn't but Alex really was like I like
this I want the attention I want to make
a big deal out of it it's good for me
and Dave publicly I think was Alex's
mindset
no but but look Alex Stein is a very
very smart guy yeah I'm on the show a
couple times he's wild he's obnoxious
but he is quick yeah like he comes up
with these one-liners and these jokes
I'm like the dude knows what he's doing
and what he's talking about he's got a
plan yeah the plan may be crazy it may
be a bit joker-ish but Stein's a smart
guy and he was like Dave I was joking
like earlier on a week ago he's like
damn I'm joking around come on let's
have fun on and Dave but Dave was
already too he was angry at that point
and I haven't seen Dave cool down yet so
what was it Chrissy Mayer said they
Waltz right in because your receptionist
is dumb and buzzed them in is that what
happened because if that's what happened
then Dave sorry you've lost every like
yeah you know every argument isn't there
also a difference between if a guy busts
in to my home at night or something then
yeah if I can get a gun I'll start
blasting away but if a guy comes into my
office well I'll just take my producer
Ben Davies and hold him right in front
of me and so you know he can take all
the bullets or anything but I'm going to
go a little bit when the pandemic was
was heating up there was a viral video
out of I think it was Los Angeles County
or something where a guy a gun A gun
shop owner said stop getting mad at me
that I can't sell you guns you voted for
this you voted for the wait periods you
voted for permitting you cannot buy guns
it's your fault people were struck up to
gun shops being like I like to buy a gun
he'd be like okay fill this form out
come back in a week and then go what I
need a gun now yeah well you voted for
it or didn't vote at all
so to have these New York City liberals
in a state that is a duty to retreat I'm
assuming New York is that way New Jersey
is that way
in New Jersey if someone breaks in your
house you have to flee your own home
to where to Florida Tennessee they
called it right exactly they call it
partial castle doctrine I talked to a
lawyer about it because someone tried
breaking in and he was like if there is
an if someone breaks in your house and
there is any way you can escape you have
to and I'm like window yep door yep jump
off the balcony and he's like within
reason obviously but like if you're in
your house and someone goes to the front
door you got to go out the back and I'm
like go where go Dunkin Donuts and then
call the cops and then I'm just like and
if there are people trapped inside
they're like well you know it's it's
it's interesting but depends on what
they're going to argue and what I was
told is that the prosecutors in Jersey
of course they will argue you did wrong
no matter what you did so that's why I
like West Virginia West Virginia someone
breaks in your house you defend yourself
the cops say shouldn't have come into
your house you get in trouble in New
York City for having pepper spray yeah
yeah it's a duty to retreat I mean I
grew up in New York City too it is yeah
it's not only your retreat it's a
retreat uh pull your pants down bend
over and yes just take it because what
else are you going to do uh other than
of course be a helpless victim as
criminals there obviously have guns
obviously they have ways of getting guns
with the Glock switches and everything
but you no you're not you're not trusted
enough to do that is it because
vigilante justice was out of control or
something
like why did they make it why can't you
just stop someone from coming into your
house in New York I don't know it's a
good question yeah well because when
cops kick your door in they don't want
to be worried about it the cops don't
want to fear that if they serve a bunk
warrant or enter the wrong house they're
gonna get a shock reprisal
because criminals are going to have guns
anyway yeah didn't Indiana pass a law
saying that if a cop wrongly enters your
home you could legally defend yourself I
think Ohio did too I think it was
Indiana yeah yeah I I saw Michael malice
tweeting about this celebrating it
really he was very Catalyst
I'm gonna look it up right now that's
amazing because you know me and Malice
are both anarchists just so you
understand where we're coming from yeah
that could explain the debate we're
having which is which is great and
awesome well I'll tell you too I was
saying this uh to malice I was saying
this to some of my more kind of iron
Randy friends because I don't I don't
like Iran Rand I went through a phase
when I was a teenager really
um I I hate Iran but the more that I
live through covid and post covid the
more that I see I don't know I'm gonna
wind up an anarchist somehow I'm gonna
wind up a Trad Anarchist I think because
you know now this is why it's also
Dave's fault if you are still conducting
business in New York or L.A
uh it's that's your fault you had plenty
of time to get out you get out like
there's no reason to stay there okay
West Virginia forcing your will onto
other people isn't cool being a statist
and authoritarian is not cool yeah
except sometimes yeah that's right if I
keep pooping in your water supply see
this is this is this is where I differ
with also you know the our the
anarchists and libertarian Friends of
the show is that
um I I look at jurisdiction right I've
had the Libertarians argue no borders
borders are imaginary anarchists borders
are imaginary and I was like
how do you protect your family if you
don't set a perimeter to where you're
allowed to live peacefully like
jurisdiction is actually setting a
limitation on yourself I actually feel
that arguing for no borders is an
extension of your authority over others
right when the United States says this
is our Southern border we're not going
to go over there well we do anyway but
the idea is this is my property line I'm
not going to go over by you this is
where I'm gonna do my thing please leave
me alone if we said borders don't matter
you're basically saying at any point I
can go over by you and do what I need to
do well and also that's just an
expression of the false anthropology at
the heart of anarchism and
libertarianism you guys are straw
Manning this I just want to say for the
record here and uh it's far more
complicated because we could get into
details like welfare and Welfare
incentivizing people to move over we
could talk about the weaponization of
immigration and I think the mises caucus
especially under uh Dave Smith has been
addressing this issue in a very smart
and correct way addressing this
immigration issue in uh in a more
correct way saying hey as as long as we
have the welfare state we shouldn't have
open immigration
you if you got rid of the welfare state
then borders should be erased or
something I mean well it depends it's a
complicated argument and there's many
different factors that are multifaceted
here to me anarchism it's not an all-end
solution to everything it's never going
to be perfect but I think as Humanity we
should always be striving for personal
responsibility and for personal freedom
and liberty and and I agree to a great
extent my concern is
the Communist Party of China exists
they've exerted authoritarian control
over their people to the extent where
they're welding them into their homes we
can be the anarchists of free trade and
all that and when the Chinese Communist
Party comes knocking and says we'd like
to purchase some land and free trade and
we say sounds good to us then before we
know it they own 40 of the Farmland on
the west coast and then all of a sudden
they're using that against us cutting
off supply lines we're being attacked
from within which means I'd love for
there with you look at the United States
and and Ron Paul made a great point that
I love where he said in the US you can
be a socialist go buy land go go set up
your little socialist commune why do you
want to force everyone else to do that
we set the boundaries we set the rules
we agree on those rules and then we can
live in peace and Harmony we're also
discussing these things as though
they're opposites when they're communism
and anarchism when in fact there are two
sides of the same coin because they
partake of the same false anthropology
which says the fundamental political
institution is the individual which is
not true and has never been true the
fundamental political unit is the family
and so people are not born as the
enlightenment of post-enlightenment
rationalists would have you believe is
individuals with a bunch of Rights and
entitlements but primarily we though we
do have rights but we are born not as
these atoms floating through space but
into families with duties and
obligations and and so your love of your
state and your love of your country is
an extension of that filial piety
because you have an obligation to to
respect your father and mother I think
centralization is is a big problem
throughout human history I think but
that's a decentralization uh essentially
this this is what kind of boils down but
again we're getting into larger ideology
but what's the balance of the two you
can't have authoritarianism or Pure
Energy you can't have
it's more than fair to say that we are
more centralized than ever and we need
more detention and this is what the
philosophy of anarchism is pushing
because right now I think it's fair to
say that too many people uh in the
central government have too much power
over everyone else and we need to limit
that and this is where we agree and I
think when you look at the political
Compass the least populated portion of
it is the center left liberal it's
either far left moderate authoritarian
to very authoritarian and then you have
moderate conservative to like
libertarian right and then you actually
I would argue have more authoritarian
right-wingers than you actually have
center-left liberal libertarian types it
just doesn't exist and the center left
lib but most people who claim B are
literally not most people claim to be
our authoritarian left want speech
policing to an extreme I was just told
that that's what I was when I took the
test this is the point and I'll get into
the next story The Point point is
if you are on the libertarian spectrum
of the political Compass you still have
a degree of authority that you expect to
exist unless you're all the way on the
bottom at Anarchy all right listen we
talked about this before on a local
small level uh you know I forgot who
said this someone more smarter than me
said this on a local family level you
should be Communists and then on a
community level you should be socialists
and then on a state level you should
move away further from centralization
and call for more decentralization and I
agree the family unit I think is one of
the most important units but I think we
also have to respect to the the the the
the strongest minority of them all and
that's the individual uh and you could
still do that while of course
prioritizing families communities and
neighborhoods and individuals coming
together to work together without any
kind of mafioso central control or
government bureaucrat coming in and
getting a cut of the money no but the
trads love subsidiarity I mean that's a
principle of uh well put forward by
Thomas Aquinas and by conservatives
since time immemorial I think the place
we're getting confused is we're
pretending that
individualism you know the anarchists
and the Communists are opposites when
they both accept the same fundamental
premise which I think is a wrong premise
which is that the individual is the
primary unit of society and so the
anarchists say it's the individual and
it has to remain that way and the
Communists say it's the individual and
that's why we've got to lump them all
together but it's the conservatives who
are offering the only genuine
alternative which says no it's actually
not about this individualism it doesn't
just come down to the individual it
comes down to something that is that is
more institutional and actually
fundamental to your Humanity which is
family and community and tradition and
not just the use of your individual
unfettered reason to come up with some
cockamami idea it's why I think Karl
Marx if you were alive today would be in
the tea party or something I absolutely
disagree with that and well it's total
Essence and when we look at essentially
what is boiling Down to What a lot of
these larger parties and ideas
especially when it comes to
conservatives and what they're doing
they're essentially just kind of the
Liberals 10 years from now when you look
at the policies when you look at them
deciding to use force and government
against other individuals to impose
their ideas I think at the end of the
day this is the key Central role when uh
anarchists and Libertarians don't want a
central figure don't want someone
telling them what to do and I think this
notion of back and forth the government
is good they're going to tell us what to
do right do they have the ultimate
decision making and what is good and bad
I think that pendulum is when it swings
back and forth between the left and
right is only bringing on more
government more authoritative
authoritarianism and I think we need a
lot less but Luke do you not see the
irony of of you know lamenting that the
wicked conservative authoritarians want
to impose their views and use this power
of the state on you when what you are
advocating is you're saying what we need
to do Michael is we need to get rid of
our political order in the United States
we need to get rid of tradition we need
to get rid of no orders
well what you are suggesting is a
radical upending of our political order
at the very least
it's not fair to put words in my mouth
I strongly believe in in families I
think they should be prioritized and I
think individuals should treat families
in a kind of communistic way on the
individual basis without any kind of
force or government intervening in that
this is why I'm a huge proponent of
homeschooling this is why I'm a huge
proponent of moving away uh from
depending on government for daily life
what if the family of responsibility
what if the families abuse kids uh
that's a horrible situation that needs
to be mitigated by the government
um that's a very hard decision that's
that's that's one example that is very
hard to deal with and again
you're making you're making this very
Niche kind of argument but I could say
what about the government raping small
children
let's keep the conversation in line and
not go that far off uh what if the
government determines that not
vaccinating your kids
is is abuse right so the the challenges
that we have and that that point right
there is why I say morality is not uh
logical morality is amorphous it's it's
an analog it's not digital we say
something like you shouldn't be allowed
to abuse your kids if a guy is beating
his child we should intervene and stop
that yeah and then someone else says
you're right and if you're not giving
the kid the appropriate medical
treatment for their disease that's abuse
and then you ask the question
which medical treatment are we talking
about are we talking about a vegan mom
who's not giving her son any meat yeah
and and because she's determined what's
right for our kids and then we intervene
or are we talking about say a gender
transition program where the government
says it's abuse if you don't give it to
him there's not a one for one answer the
only and I I agree with that of course
the only point I'm trying to make is
that I find libertarianism and anarchism
to be extremely authoritarian in as much
as they seek to impose a political order
on me that I think is absurd and that I
don't want I don't want to live in a
political order in which I in a
self-government cannot through my
representatives and through the police
force take a child out of an abusive
home a Libertarian or an anarchist might
prefer that but that's not what I want
so I find it very authoritarian but you
would rather have a government and
support a government and pay taxes to a
government that's running international
trafficking or organizations
if he's making an argument saying I
support you know but I can make the same
argument there no I never said here's
the idea the ideal is if a guy punches a
kid in the face we protect that kid and
get it away from that person if a guy's
beating his wife we get his wife out of
there but then there's a simple
challenge the law says you shall not
cause physical harm to your children or
your spouse be it male or female and
then we say that's a fine law you cannot
physically harm and then someone goes
this woman was giving her kid an also a
diet with no protein and he's sickly
anemic and about to die we sort of have
do we intervene in that regard but the
mother says I know what's right for my
kid then we say okay you're right she's
abusing the kid then someone says oh but
there the government Dr fauci says this
vaccine is has to be for kids and the
parent won't do it should the government
then intervene it's the same law right
and so interpreted in different
scenarios traditionally the American
response to this is that we have a
self-government and to your point Luke
very often it does not appear that we
actually have a self-government
increasingly but notionally that's the
idea at least and So within this
self-government we have the right as
Citizens to come to answers on the
questions and say you know the all soy
diet that is abusive you're not allowed
to do that the vaccine no we're not
going to make you vaccinate your kids
and that's particular but that does mean
that we have the right to impose our
views of the world on others that is the
premise and prerequisite of
self-government if you do not do that
then well you'll have to impose some
other political order which will get you
right back to the same time let me ask
you Luke uh if a kid had strep throat
bacterial and the doctor said we're
gonna I don't know what the actual
treatment is amoxicillin do they still
do much yeah
and the mother says no I don't want any
of that weird stuff we're going to give
him tree bark do you think the
government should intervene or just let
the Kid die there's there's a lot of
variables in that particular situation
so again hypotheticals are not my
favorite I don't think it's fair to even
issue a lot of those kind of things
I don't try and patter your way out I'm
not patterning my way I'm addressing the
situation I don't I don't think it's a
fair it's I don't think it's a fair
question now obviously how's it not a
fair question a kid has a very simply
curable bacterial infection and the mom
doesn't want to give him medicine should
the government intervene
um
at this instant in this current
situation uh the government will
intervene but nobody should should the
internet I don't have all the answers
this is the challenge when I start
thinking about how yes I want to be much
more libertarian I don't like vaccine
mandates and when we say something like
look I've had uh when I was a kid you
know strep throat or whatever and they
gave me that pink stuff that tasted
really really great it was like
strawberry flavored amoxicillin or
something and it cures you we know
antibiotics cure diseases shout out to
fungus shout out to fungus so if I see a
parent who's like I'm gonna rub crystals
on my kid I'm like well look I don't
like the idea that the government can
come in and tell a parent how to raise
their kid that's a big problem but
there's also
oh man what do you do we know that that
anti-antibiotics can cure certain
diseases
how do we navigate this when Dr fauci
says You must do this for your kid right
even if it's like you know like and
we're in phase three trials it's only
been a couple years at that point you're
like I object
but it's this at the core the Nuance of
the situation is different but it's the
same thing do I accept the government
can intervene when a person defies the
net the the science
man now I'm like I'm watching a kid die
a strep throat when I know he could save
his life because I don't want someone to
be forced to inject their kid over here
I don't have the answer well there's
also one there's a difference between
amoxicillin and the fauci algae you know
we have a lot more long-term data on one
of those than the other but but also to
your point can the government do this
there is an historical matter here which
you've which you've pointed out Luke
which is that
throughout all of human history in every
single Society in every single place on
planet Earth the the government by which
we mean people having power within
political communities do impose those
things every single place occasionally
anarchists will say you know in 8th
Century Iceland or something but you
know okay fine but every everywhere yeah
okay right right if you look at
government interventions I mean again
anarchism doesn't have all the solutions
doesn't have all the answers and I do
believe children should always be
protected obviously that should be a
comment no no no hold on hold on but
hold on I've got to address the point
okay but this is the larger point that I
wanted to make here I'm not finished
here I'm laying down the groundwork for
this point but you don't agree with that
you don't think kids should always be
protected it depends on the
circumstances and situations I don't
want to be the central controller
deciding a lot of these things a lot of
these things will be decided by
individuals or communities or families
and neighborhoods that will decide for
themselves of what is right and I
believe at the end of the day that is a
better thing that will happen rather
than a government coming in and taking a
kid and putting them into CPS
look at how horrible our CPS system is
look at how many kids get hurt inside of
the CPS system I have a question so so
all I'm saying is at the end of the day
I don't have all the answers and
solutions here no one does obviously
there's flaws in every single political
argument and political ideology yes so
obviously but at the end of the day
individuals should decide for themselves
not Central controllers so let me ask a
simple question
two circumstances
government says we will not intervene in
what the family decides to do with their
child the family then decides they will
sterilize and castrate their kid and
give them hormones
second scenario you mean what they're
doing right now with family protection
second scenario family says we will not
give this kid hormone therapy and
surgery and the government does
intervene right which one's the right or
wrong one do we say the government
should not intervene in the parents
decision as they decide to give their
kid what they deem best a sex change or
do we stop the government from forcing
the sex change because the child wants
it and the state beams need to be taking
responsibility away from yourself taking
decisions away from the family from the
community is to me a recipe
that's my main argument do you think not
some emotional argument about kicking a
baby
if a mother and father publicly announce
that their child of 12 wants to be
castrated and injected with hormones
should we just say that's your choice as
a parent
um I I think that should be pushed back
against it in many different ways uh
that's a horrible decision decision
that's going to hurt the child and I
think they should there should at least
be informed consent and some Community
involvement How can there be
participation for the kid well there's
the thing kids should always be
protected this is where I disagree with
a lot of the bigger kind of libertarian
and Anarchist ideas especially when they
say we got to sell heroin to kids
obviously that's the wrong idea
obviously that's something that that I I
stand against and I made clear many
times before on this particular show but
when it comes to these important
decision making decisions at the end of
the day I do believe and I have a lot
more faith in a family in a community in
the neighborhood and in individuals
rather than the big government that we
have now that uses our tax dollars in
horrible ways and hurts way more people
than the larger ideologies of anarchism
which I believe at the end of the day
would lead to less harm reduction I just
wanted to say that that scenario I gave
of the parents are doing it and the
government doesn't intervene and the
parents don't want it the government
does intervene is exemplifies my point
about how laws are based on amorphous
morals analog morals like
in which circumstance do we decide the
government is or isn't right well and
also the the interpretation of
intervention here is I think problematic
because the the government by which and
Luke you keep conflating these things
where you say well no I don't like the
government I just like Community well
the government is the expression of the
political Community especially in a
notionally self-governing especially now
what's happening with the elections
especially now with the way that they're
running things certain elections are an
expression but we're following maybe not
Maricopa County yeah especially now how
much debt they put us in especially now
I mean the national debt is an
expression of the political community of
making choices absolutely this is how I
I drift more away from anarchism and
libertarianism I recognize sometimes we
want the government to intervene and
sometimes we don't
and it's it there's no way to define it
other than a judgment it just seems like
a person it seems to me the government
the government is always intervening in
the sense that we live in a society we
live in a political community in order
to live together in a society we come up
with rules and norms and institutions to
mediate the people in that Society the
families and the but why can't
communities do that why do you need a
government to do that that is what a
government is this is the expression of
a pla the the expression I think that's
been highly bastardized and highly
incorrect with the way the government is
now you're talking about federal
government and large government right
you're advocating for smaller localized
government I'm talking what essentially
is a mafia coming in there and saying I
will impose my will on you because I
know what's best for you I'm against
those ideas but but when we're talking
about let's just use the term political
Community then because which I think is
actually more precise within a political
Community
there is always a way that people are
living and being raised so for instance
if the mode of Education within the
political Community says that men and
women are different and Men Can't become
women and women can't become men then I
guess you're not going to have these
kids getting castrated and injected with
with poison but is that the government
intervening I just think this idea that
the government is active or passive is
no the government just is the political
Community just is and we're always
constantly living in a state of
standards and norms and so the question
is not this procedural question is will
the government do something or not the
question is just what is the government
doing well so here's what I see
we have no willingness in American
society to set standards and uphold them
there's a bifurcation politically as we
call the Multicultural democracy and the
Constitutional republicanists that's
basically how it's breaking breaking
down but this means that for the most
part antifa goes around smashing windows
and there is no willpower or desire to
stop them well we just got an article of
five of them getting arrested we do have
this story in the school councils I just
want to make one quick Point here
because I just agree with one one basic
Point here were you saying the
government is a representation of
community there's been many scientific
studies showing specifically that the
will of the people does not impose or
change the government it is special
interest I'm not talking about the
wonderful people that do
representative hold on hold on and the
government is by and large a tool of a
lot of powerful we're talking about one
specific government versus the concept
of government different things but let
me pull up the story real quick sorry
guys but this is great it's okay I mean
this is we're having a great time I'm
enjoying this until like 30 degrees
questioning my ideas I love this this is
this is big news we got Andy no reports
from the post-millennial domestic Terror
charges for five arrested at violent
antifa autonomous Zone near Atlanta the
Georgia Bureau of Investigations has
found explosive devices and gasoline at
the rate the reason this story is
newsworthy is that it actually happened
for once yeah you know if if the law was
being upheld as it's supposed to be we
wouldn't care to talk about another
bunch of extremists getting arrested
they're supposed to get arrested now
we're like wow look at that they
actually arrested some of them here's
what I see happening this is the point I
was making just in the previous segment
our society
typically a cohesive one everybody kind
of agrees on the lines you don't cross
when someone crosses that line everyone
is aghast and the cops are like we're
going to go in and deal with this that
meant obscenity laws 100 years ago that
meant someone could go on a street
corner and yell something nasty and
they'd be like no no stop the stop this
and everyone agreed not good we've now
gone so far in the other direction that
you actually have people throwing
Molotov cocktails and in these cities
they're like well you know it's their
first offense and look we're going to
lose votes if we actually prosecute
these people so let's let them all out
of the prisons now there's no
enforcement at all the American people I
mean it's conservatives too
I mean conservatives aren't going to go
to cities and demand this stuff
so unless there was an actual
ramification for not holding people to
account
you know or I should say there is no
ramification for not holding people to
account so it's just not happening this
is this is the breakdown of the
political body or of government or
whatever you want to call it though
their their people are being held to
account if for instance they uh prohibit
their children from being castrated
people are being held to account if they
walk into the capital rotunda with a
horn hat on and crack a Coors Light
people are having the book thrown at
them for that sort of thing pro-life
activists at abortion clinic pro-life
activists at abortion clinics and just
even exposing crimes actual Elite not
just immoral activity which is all that
takes place at abortion clinics but but
actual illegal activity and then who's
prosecuted it's the pro-lifers so the
law the law is being enforced and more
than the law is being enforced against
certain people but you know you look at
say the 19th century early 20th century
and you always see these Horror Stories
of the Ku Klux Klan getting away with
lynchings or Terror rides or anything
like that you say well they just didn't
enforce the law you know that was yeah
right that is is an imperfect expression
of how the law is enforced and you're
seeing you're seeing precisely the same
sort of thing here it's cultural
tolerance right now our culture is
completely tolerating antifa
conservatives and libertarian types
complain about the violence and that's
and then nothing else happens there is
no cost for a law enforcement division
of any kind if they do not enforce the
law there is a cost right if they do
enforce it when they come out and Target
antifa they can expect more fire bombs
and more violence if they don't arrest
anybody what can they expect well there
will be some firebombs and violence from
these lunatics they won't arrest but
conservatives ain't going to do anything
yeah but you do see uh the law of nature
take over when the firebombed Duane
reader when they go into Dwayne Reed and
MOB the store the flash mob and Rob you
know a thousand dollars each so they
can't get felonies in San Francisco
where they made it your louder a
thousand bucks and then Dwayne Reed
shuts down I think it's Duane Reade
don't give me if it's not Dwayne I think
it was Dwayne Reed there's also uh I
think target so you see the market is
reacting to unchecked violence it's not
the right maybe it's not even though
it's culture it's the market itself but
that's part of the culture the mayor but
it's like it's like a team of nature the
mayor the chief of police the the the
the the sheriffs they suffer no
consequence no immediate consequence
it's a long-term thing where your city
starts to fall apart business is shut
down the individual suffers no
consequence at all well only that your
your environment begins to degrade
slowly so what they can move
so these cops these cops who live in San
Francisco they're resigning they're
moving and then it gets worse and worse
and worse and that is an issue of uh of
an individualized society when everyone
just says it's about me and my life
that's what happens when people put
responsibility to the community slightly
above themselves you'll get someone
going out being like I gotta stop this
because you know old man Jenkins down
the street needs this Dwayne reefer's
medication I can't let someone do this
to the community
let's let's break this problem down
because I think it's fair to say that
George Soros invested a lot when it came
to appointing District Attorneys and
attorney generals all throughout the
United States you guys agree with 120
million so so Republicans bought
government to impose his will on what he
thought was right and his will is
punishing right Wingers but letting
antifa go well for the most part it's
the unin the the non-enforcement George
Soros wrote an op-ed about how he wanted
DA's who were not going to go after
people and we're going to give them
lighter sentences that's an inversion
I'm not advocating for Harsh
authoritarianism so I I actually think
cash bail is a problem but I don't know
if we have the solution other than to
expand build more courts hire more
judges but George Soros basically said I
want people who are in the DA's office
who won't prosecute crimes well you got
it and now it's getting worse exactly
but that's not using the government to
do it that's stripping the government of
the ability to stop these people no no
no no no because when the government
sees a right-winger when the government
sees a political crime when the
government sees a way to punish someone
for their political ideas they do it
that's that's the government there okay
when it comes too specifically when it
comes to specifically made a point I'm
going to address your point Luke you
made one point let me address it if
there's a left-wing and right-wing
activists and they both Riot they should
both be arrested what's happened now is
half is being enforced and politically
biased only one side is being let go
this is the government
not enforcing half of it and actually
and and upscaling against the right and
by the way not to be too harsh you know
on the libertarian effect on the
conservative movement but a lot of the
reason why the libs have become so good
specifically over the last 60 years at
wielding the government in a way that it
was not very good actually at before you
saw you know you saw the beginnings of
Woodrow Wilson and FDR but you still had
a lot of conservative political power
within the government a lot of the
reason why we're not good at it anymore
is because the Libertarians convinced
the conservatives that wielding
political power per se is wrong and
immoral and by doing that we conceded
the entire political field and now the
libs run all of the institutions the
conservatives and Republicans being weak
has nothing to do with Libertarians they
decided that for themselves and they
capitulated power they're the ones that
went along with a lot of this nonsense
they're the ones that are literally just
the Democrats of 10 years ago let's be
honest here they're implementing the
same policies and and if there ever is a
political party that hasn't been working
for the American people that actually
screwed them over and and gave them
failed promises you're right it's the
Republican Party what's your opinion on
redefining marriage the obergeophile
case and the now the law that was passed
yesterday the quote unquote respect for
Marriage Act radically redefines the
fundamental political institution
I think it's a PR stunt uh in order to
try to Galvanize a base pretty much I
have a marriage I haven't even I haven't
even read the bill I haven't even what
about the concept I don't I don't
believe the government should I don't
think you need permission to marry
someone to get a license from the
government well you always have
throughout all of human history so how
come how come now people no no not
always people made bonds and and
specific contracts with each other
without without government sometimes as
well that's not true marriage has always
had a tie either too religion or to the
religion which was usually established
and that tied to the state I'll make
I'll make a single thing that's why
sometimes sometimes religion was more
powerful than this and let me know
specifically but they're always tied
together and I'll address specifically
pre-marriage pre no fault divorce was a
contract that you could not just break
if you entered into a contract with
someone you had a duty and
responsibility and if you wanted to
break it you had to prove to a court
that was just reason to do so right so a
marriage meant something the reason you
had the government involved wasn't
because they gave you permission it was
because you were saying to another
person I give my life to you I expect
your life in return it's a public act
and it's a public act and if that person
then decided I'm not going to give you
equal like you're giving me your life
I'm not giving you back you would have
your honor courts I need this enforced
and they would say marriage counseling
some kind of relationship counseling
then no fault divorce came in and now
we're at the when the period where
marriage is basically a date you're
dating someone someone there's no
enforcement anymore 40s which I think is
interesting the reason why
libertarianism is so popular right now
is because in the 40s America became a
militant authoritarian country it used
to be a liberal Republic and then in
1949 when they signed they created the
liberal economic order they became this
a military government and they did it in
secret they didn't want want people to
know Kennedy tried to out on the kill
whoever someone killed him and uh who is
they
pollution of government from Liberty
Liberty State yeah and so what's
happening is the um the anarchists are
pushing back but the way if you push
back too hard the pendulum goes extreme
you don't want extreme that's what
status do left and right left and right
back and forth more government more
government more government listen I grew
up in Poland when there's still
communism there right the Polish people
are adverse to Communists and to
fascists to extreme left and extreme
right this is essentially the larger
ideas that are Quantified in anarchism
in my opinion because they push back a
lot of this nonsense that feeds each
other and builds on top of each other
and in Poland specifically when it came
to things like marriage right if someone
would be divorced if someone would not
take care of their child after birthing
a child they would be looked upon as a
scumbag there would be social pressures
on that individual for being a scumbag
no one's a very Catholic well during
communism and during when the Soviet
Union had control of of Poland it wasn't
it wasn't mainly the the state that was
enforced in a lot of these morals it was
church that had a larger impact on that
well it was the church was suppressed
and the church was fighting the the
state so right but my point here is when
when I hear from our libertarian friends
that the conservatives are actually the
ones who were the Democrats from 10
years ago
is it not true no it's not true the
Libertarians are the ones who are
pushing gay marriage of you so left-wing
that Barack Obama didn't even agree with
it in 2011. they're the ones pushing
drugs they're the ones pushing open
borders they're the ones pushing all of
the breakdown of the family though some
are but I'm not some are yes those are
issues
against I think you unwittingly are
pushing those things but you I don't
think I understand yeah I disagree
because I addressed those problems uh
specifically uh what was the three that
I guess the reason the reason I bring it
up is if you ask real conservatives the
real tragedy is around today what's your
view on marriage they're going to give
you the view of marriage that was held
from the beginning of human history
until 2015. if you ask their views on
drug laws or on a punishing criminals or
on immigration enforcement or any of
these things you're going to get the
conservative point of view and it's
going to be the Libertarians and the
liberals who agree on all of those
issues in a very very radical way
I disagree I think the ideology is is
directly opposed to each other liberals
want more government Libertarians want
less government but but but
it's the same as what I'm saying because
it's not when the Liberals use big
government in order to impose their vote
but when the when the Libertarians uh
use this Fantastical utopian aversion to
government to break down the social
order and to break everyone down into to
individuals who are much more easily
collectivized which is which is
something you said brilliant I don't
know where you got this idea that the
base unit of a of a of society is the is
a duality it's a communication between
two or more people a family unit one
individual born in the woods with no
humans is not a human I mean technically
they're human they're not not a person
they're not Society yeah they don't have
man they don't understand language they
don't understand concepts of humanity
they don't understand they're a wild
animal if they're born in the woods yeah
right alone yeah and so you need that
second person and I think to think of
society as The Duality we cannot
function without The Duality because
that's what like it keeps you sane it
keeps you humble it's the man and the
woman yeah I thought that was really
funny The Matrix you see the fourth
Matrix one they made I I didn't know
they went up to four I think I've only
seen through three I think it's funny
because a lot of people said it was
gonna be like woke or whatever but the
plot of The Matrix is literally that you
need a matriarch and a patriarch
together to stabilize reality and not in
a Libertarian Society not only will two
people keep each other sane and rational
but in a in a totalitarian Society two
people will keep each other from falling
victim to the state we have to move on
to at least one more story because
there's no way I can let this one go so
I got a hard segue to Rolling Stone
Trump's major announcement was a scammy
superhero themed nft collection for 99
you can now own a digitally generated
image of the former president cosplaying
as an astronaut fighter pilot sheriff or
red carpet celebrity uh I think it's
hilarious his video release was really
funny he goes uh hopefully I'm your
favorite President greater than Lincoln
greater than Washington and if you and
if you buy an nft you enter into a
sweepstakes for a chance to win a bunch
of great prizes like dinner with me I
don't know if it's a great prize but
maybe but it's what we got but I think
it was funny that he's like I'm better
than Lincoln and Washington and eating
dinner with me might not be a good prize
so so look he's a funny guy I think what
was cringe about this was that people
thought he was going to endorse someone
for RNC chair he was going to announce a
VP he was going to put forth a major
policy proposal but instead he's selling
nfts right around the time FTX collapses
and what six months after nfts became
worthless yeah yeah sorry how many did
you buy oh seven no I bought none I'm
not gonna buy it I'm trying so hard
because I I still really like the guy
best present in my lifetime but I'm
trying really hard to spin it in my head
I'm like how can I convince myself this
was a good announcement and I I can't do
it you know but but the the thing that
his announcement did demonstrate is
something that I have I have said to
Trump's critics for years which is they
say he's an egomaniac narcissist
yeah you know he has his name on
buildings but he has a kind of humility
like for instance he had this comment
when he was president he said
someone accused him of drinking a beer
he said I've never drunk a beer okay
I've never I'm probably the only
President could say I've never drunk a
beer it's the only good thing you can
say about me and it was an expression of
humility it was a self-effacing thing as
he is saying here you know when he when
he boasts about everything he's talking
like a New Yorker but he's usually
joking I I just I I laughed so hard when
he was like maybe it's not a good prize
I don't know I'm like that was
masterfully done he's really good at
that kind of stuff yeah I mean he's
getting a lot of pushback especially
from a lot of his supporters today
America needs a superhero big
announcement tomorrow here's my Pokemon
cards and I'm like you got to be kidding
me and uh look at this look at this oh
yeah this is a good look at it look at
look at he's shooting lasers infomercial
hello everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
Washington with an important
announcement to make I'm doing my first
official Donald J Trump nft collection
right here and right now they're called
Trump digital trading cards these cards
feature some of the really incredible
artwork pertaining to my life and my
career it's not very exciting you can
collect your Trump digital cards just
like a baseball card or other
Collectibles here's one of the best
parts each card comes with an automatic
chance to win amazing prizes like dinner
with me I don't know if that's an
amazing prize that's what we have we're
golfing but it's what we have your
friends at one of my beautiful golf
courses yeah uh the prizes actually are
great like having a cocktail party with
your friends at Mar-A-Lago it's not a
bad product I mean that sounds really
fun dinner with Trump would be extremely
interesting even if you don't like the
guy and playing golf with him that
sounds about a hundred dollar gambling
chip to find hope you win a chance to
hang out it's like not in this economy
now no no no I I think I think the whole
thing was a mistake they should be 99
cents each and he could sell 100 million
of them or 10 million or 50 million
why do you gotta do bump stock Donnie
like that Tim yeah I thought you liked
him yeah why you gotta do them like that
I like I like the Abraham Accords I like
trying to negotiate peace with North
Korea I like setting timelines for
withdrawal from the Middle East I don't
like him for a whole lot of reasons
there's a tweet going around right now
allegedly from Baked Alaska saying quote
I can't believe I'm going to jail for an
nft salesman
this does bring some interesting
comments to where Trump's attention is
he's not on Twitter he's not in the
National discourse he's not making you
know a lot of strong stances on a lot of
the important things happening right now
he's selling 99 nfts now here's the
problem almost immediately right after
we have this story shatter the left-wing
censorship regime Trump announces 2024
Free Speech policy quote a Sinister
group of deep State bureaucrats Silicon
Valley tyrants and activists and
depraved corporate news media have been
conspiring to manipulate and silence the
American people this was a very somber
and serious statement that came out like
right around the time as this nft
announcement
this should have been the major
announcement of course people have been
like wow Trump's getting serious what's
the announcement he's promising he's
going to do something when he becomes
president of the United States that
doesn't I mean change it's a politician
making promises it doesn't really change
anything that's a good point but but the
point is Donald Trump has an
announcement to make and at the very
least it would have been in of political
nature not selling nfts you know I'm I'm
all for the fun frivolity silliness I
mean I like that but it it has to that
has to be the cherry on top of the
Sunday of really doing something and
talking about issues that people care
about I mean to your point look he's not
in office right now so he can't really
do anything and he's not even on Twitter
so he can't talk that much but I just I
look and I think in Trump 2015 when also
he was just talking right he was just a
candidate but Trump 2015 he comes down
that escalator he says what no other
Republican will say which is that this
immigration thing is horrible and
they're sending rapists and drug dealers
across and we got to do something when
he said you remember Hillary Clinton's
uh slogan was I'm with her and Trump
said that's a BS slogan I'm with you you
switch the subject and the he said I'm
with you and you really felt like this
guy's talking about things that actually
matter to me NAFTA when was the last
Republican to challenge NAFTA ever you
know Buchanan I guess and and now you
all we're seeing is the frivolity all
we're seeing is the tihi you know here's
and I just think okay it's funny come on
give me something man he he uh and it uh
in this statement he said within hours
of my inauguration I will sign an
executive order Banning any any federal
department or agency from colluding with
any organization business or person to
censor limit categorize or impede the
lawful speech of American citizens I
will then ban Federal money from being
used to label domestic speech Miss
orders information I'll begin the
process of identifying and firing every
Federal bureaucrat who has engaged in
domestic censorship directly or
indirectly et cetera et cetera I I it's
it's it's topical it's playing to what's
going on with Elon and Twitter if this
was his major announcement it would have
played very well if he came out and said
what we have recently discovered in
several lawsuits as well as leaked
information from Big social networks
that the government had been colluding
as president I will end this people
would be like wow you know what Elon
Musk Twitter files just came out then
Donald Trump says I'm paying attention I
know what is worrying you and I will
address it would have been big it is big
in a sense it's just being overshadowed
by his weird late night infomercial you
know nft thing it could be he released
the nfts and then the Management's like
oh my God this is backfiring this is not
telling quick make a statement make a
statement what are you gonna do as
president I'm gonna do this I promise
this politicians make promises all the
time they rarely ever keep them
especially if they're campaigning how do
you know a politician's lying they're
campaigning that's when you know their
life is moving um no he kept more than
than most politicians and he didn't keep
all of it and they're not even close but
he kept a lot but previously before
before he became president of the United
States he promised to audit the Federal
Reserve he promised to investigate 911
he promised to look into Saudi Arabia's
involvement in 911 I mean he was talking
about a lot of big things you know again
didn't really kind of address them when
he was president but people don't want
to hear that people want to hear how is
he going to in Pennsylvania how is he
going to win Arizona because right now
there's no political road map for him
winning how why you'd have to talk about
graphing the only way no no I'm talking
about balance
I'm talking about ballot Harvest
I think he ends onto something if Donald
Trump comes out and says we don't need
your vote as long as we Advocate
graphene we're going to get every vote
anyway
industrial nation on Earth We're Gonna
Leave the 21st century with the new
material metabolism it's all around him
no hold on hold on you know look at our
smug face is here we're all laughing
yeah but there there is a version of
reality where Donald Trump says forget
the politicking forget the gamesmanship
forget the ballot harvesting he walks
out and says graphene is a Wonder
material that will change everything and
bring jobs back and everyone just goes
he's right 100 million votes trying to
build a space elevator we're going to
lead the lead the world in space
exploration like we need him telling us
what he wants to create for the species
if he has any chance of winning so
graphene's a metaphor he needs to talk
about his plans to build and help
America and to call out those who seek
his destruction like he was doing in
2016. yeah graphene's literal you need
we're gonna make space elevator tethers
out of it I think what you're really
saying is no that is you're right you're
literally she needs a message about
industry some sort of Industry that's
what we need right now is industry we
don't need who's better we don't need to
see who's got the longer you know I'm
I'm not sure I'm no longer graphing
remember I'm not gonna no longer tether
I'm not going to defend the nft thing
there are people who are coming out
saying it was a troll I'm like dude get
out of here the dude's selling you stuff
I really want to vote for Donald Trump I
want there to be a reason to do so I
want to see his narrative art completed
but it does feel to me that he's finding
a way to bow out that's it yeah someone
you think he's like on retirement I said
homie's retirement in 2016 he's like you
know effectively calling Rose O'Donnell
a fat pig he's calling out the machine
he's mocking them openly to their faces
Michael Moore says he was a human
Molotov cocktail it was revenge for all
of the establishment games selling jobs
selling factories Outsourcing and
gutting this country 2020. I I see what
he did after he got like I I don't want
to vote for that guy but then I'm like
the economy is doing really well
pre-covered yeah he's Abraham Accords
he's got a bunch of Peace deals he's
actively trying to work on peace in the
Middle East and in North Korea and I'm
like okay school choice was a big thing
Banning uh uh um bump stock no that was
bad but Banning the woke stuff from
Government Contracting I'm like not
perfect the bomb stock ban was very bad
his statements were very bad but I said
the piece in the Middle East stuff that
he's working on not perfect I get it I
will take it especially over Joe Biden
so I voted for him now all he's doing is
talking about 2020. he's tweeting about
his true thing about it non-stop selling
nfts and we get only tiny morsels of
some kind kind of policy position so I'm
just like dude you had me with the 2020
campaign I can now see what what what in
2016 worked why is it that now is winter
2024 he's giving us his garbage hey no
no he's also telling us to get
vaccinated so remember to do that folks
well this is you know Ron DeSantis is
what I I know that some people don't
like Ron DeSantis or they used to like
Ron DeSantis but now they don't like Ron
DeSantis because Trump is running and
and whatever you think about the guy he
is one of the most masterful politicians
of our lifetime and he has found this
one issue in particular where he can
outflank Trump to the right and that's
on the vaccines and choosing to empanele
that grand jury and choosing to
investigate the MRNA Vex I mean it was
an absolute stroke of Genius and I don't
know how Trump answers that he can't
yeah we didn't especially when it came
to lockdowns when it came to covet and
when it came to operation warp speed he
can't so DeSantis just had a panel with
Joe latapo his uh secretary uh secretary
the the Surgeon General Surgeon General
and uh what was it exactly can you
explain the panel that that they had
because I saw 10 20 seconds of it so
that well they're they're like five or
six
things that DeSantis is proposing right
now the most important one though is is
actually impaneling a grand jury to
investigate and potentially prosecute
the people who lied about these vaccines
from industry to to Public Authority and
so that that's a big deal because you
need teeth I mean as we're all kind of
talking about it's one thing to make a
promise on a campaign Trail or to send a
tweet but if you're actually holding
people to account for deception and
fraud and crimes you know those are the
kind of results that that people want
and and so look I don't blame Trump
entirely for kovid I don't think any
politician in his shoes would have
handled it all that much better at the
national level but who knows it's a
Sweden pretty good we gotta go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends and become a member over at
timcast.com because we're going to have
I can only imagine it's going to be a
hilarious big debate members only
segment where we'll get back into all of
the State versus Liberty versus
conservatism stuff but we can talk about
seed oils
timcast.com click join us but let's uh
read your super chats Arrow says please
talk about Ecto life's artificial womb
facility I'm not familiar dude oh my
gosh yeah I played that video in the
beginning of one of my reports it's it's
a it's not a real video yeah it is a
fake it's a fake video of what is is
essentially a plan for the Matrix but
the Matrix in in you know people being
forced to make genetically engineered
babies it was like a warehouse of like
incubators basically yeah but it's all
Graphics it's all fake it's not real but
but that's a concept that they're trying
to make into a real idea grafty says my
throat hurts from laughing but but thank
you for the super chats
well what do we got Clint Torres says
Tim I think you have an interesting
perspective regarding the death penalty
I also think Michael has an equally
interesting yet different perspective
that I think is worth talking about uh I
oppose a death penalty mostly because
in order for it to happen you need
people I'll use the worst example
possible Kamala Harris comes to me and
says trust me Tim this guy should die
I'm gonna be like no way dude you know
if if there's a circumstance where I
know definitively that someone is an
active threat then I believe the use of
force which which ultimately including
capital punishment uh capital punishment
is still hard for me but I suppose there
is a circumstance where if you could if
you could if it was proven to me
definitively as a like absolute this
person will be a threat to society
unless he is he is dead then I would be
okay I get it so you you but you you
think that the death penalty is only
Justified to protect the society to to
stop someone from causing harm and
destroying but you don't think it would
be justified for Retribution no I don't
I don't I don't believe in retribution
really well I shouldn't say it that way
because in certain circumstances I would
I want to be absolute I don't think I
think I think that if you subdue the
threat the only real question beyond
that point is should we extend our labor
and resources to providing for someone
who has effectively forfeited their
right to society if you kill them though
then you're not providing for them and
the challenge I have there is
in a perfect system like I just I don't
like the idea of killing something
that's not a threat I'd rather put them
on a boat and kick him out but then the
problem is they're still a threat you
know what I mean yeah yeah Exile doesn't
work so ultimately in a in a realistic
scenario my issue with the death penalty
is there's no government Authority that
I will trust that someone deserves to
die what about deep things they're going
to show you video of someone getting
killed and they'll be like that's why I
saw it I guess the reason I keep trying
to hone in on this is if if you'd oppose
a death penalty because you don't trust
the government that's one thing but if
you oppose the death penalty even if you
knew the guy did it you know for the
purposes of Retribution that's different
because there are three purposes of
Criminal Justice deterrence
Rehabilitation and retribution
and we only ever talk about those first
two now right and so it's deterrence
well you know you've got uh well and
what's funny is the opponents of the
death penalty always downplay deterrence
they say it doesn't actually deter
people and which is controversial but
also we don't really enforce the death
penalty anymore so it's like of course
it's not deterring people we don't
actually enforce it uh but but then
Rehabilitation is when everyone focuses
on they say that the the re the only
reason to punish people is to
rehabilitate them bring them back into
society obviously the death penalty
doesn't do that so I think it actually
does I think Dr Johnson is right when he
says depend upon it sir when a man knows
he's to be hanged in a fortnight it
concentrates his mind wonderfully I
think it can rehabilitate a man a lot
better than maybe 30 years in prison but
but furthermore the primary purpose of
the criminal justice system up to and
including capital punishment but the
whole thing it seems to me is
retribution well do you think it's it's
true people for committing crimes do you
think is but I don't I don't I my My
Philosophy is we Rehabilitation should
be number one but but uh if we say that
the primary purpose of jails is
Rehabilitation then we could all be sent
to jails today I mean we could all use a
little bit of Rehabilitation right the
reason we're not is because we didn't
commit any crimes no but of course like
I don't mean that I'm saying if someone
breaks the law we want to say okay we
want to eliminate the threat you pose to
society and work towards no longer
having you be a threat to society but
you don't yeah you don't you don't think
though that though deterrence and
Rehabilitation are good secondary
effects of punishment do you not think
that given given I think we would all
agree the purpose of the jails and the
prisons is to punish people for
committing crime so the purpose is
retribution even though if you think
well I don't really care that much well
no no I think it is but I disagree with
that I think it's caused problems for us
what problems do you think we end up
with massive criminal populations that
just Harden each other we you end up
with low tier criminals who go in and
become worse criminals then get out and
they extend their life of crime
perpetually and so my issue is like how
do we actually just stop all of it how
do we how do we stop the recidivism if
we're telling someone you did wrong pay
the price they go okay you know I'll be
out in a year and then they go right
back to doing exactly what they were
doing so we should put a heavier focus
on okay how do we make you not do that
now there's some stupid answers like
let's pay criminals not to commit crimes
I'm like no that's dumb someone will
commit a crime on purpose just to get
but I think we agree on this we agree
that you should rehabilitate criminals
when you can and once they've paid their
debt to society they get out hopefully
we can reintegrate them into society I
just the the reason retribution is an
emotional satisfaction that we pay money
for no I think it's Justice I mean I
think it's giving people what they
deserve and so with retribution you know
it it a lot of people say that this is
an attack on human dignity especially
when it comes to Capital Punishment they
say we believe in human dignity and so
therefore we can't have it but you know
when it comes from is the Book of
Genesis whosoever sheds the blood of Man
by man shall his blood be shed because
man is made in the image and likeness of
God so it's actually because we take
human dignity seriously that's why we
believe that if you harm people and
especially if you kill people then we're
going to kill you right back do you
think that sadism has a place in
Christianity no well
it's a very big question because finding
joy and the pain of others is kind of
like Rich what I see of Israel let's get
some more Super chats in sorry I don't
know it's a good it's a good question
all right Collision akov says people
claiming that Trump's nft scam is
trolling is the saddest cope I've seen
from the right there are a thousand ways
to raise money from passionate
unrepresented people and an F nft scam
ain't it
I wouldn't call it a scam it's
commercial product uh Trump's found a
way to make art that people might want
and I think people can bite if they want
to uh I would encourage people to buy it
if they like the pictures I think some
think some of the pictures are funny I
think the prizes are great I think
what's cringe about it is that Trump
said we need a superhero and I've got a
major announcement but it was just him
selling a product did he declare for
president yet because this is okay so
this is campaign financing
presumably I actually don't know I mean
you guys don't right click those photos
now don't do it that's bad Jeremiah says
someone made Michael Knowles I identify
as correct into a YouTube short it's one
of the funniest shorts I've ever seen I
saw that interview tell us about it you
know so it refers to I had this gal on
Bronte remzick who's uh pro-abortion med
student and saw that did you see that so
we had this two and a half hour
conversation and uh it it veered off at
one point
because you know when she was talking
about abortion she even kind of admitted
by the end she said yeah okay we should
ban late term abortion she she seemed to
come over more to more to the pro-life
side than she already was but what held
her up was the the trans thing
because she she said Michael when we're
talking about pregnant people and I said
hey you mean mothers as well if you want
to say that they're not all mothers you
know I said well who which ones aren't
mothers you know and she got really hung
up on it and and so I said okay Bronte
you believe that we need to affirm
everyone's self-identity I identify as
correct and more correct than you so do
you affirm that and it's I guess that's
a good point thank you because you know
I realized you know I I was just a line
that sort of came to me but
it is the answer to this question
because a lot of times what
conservatives will do is they'll say
well I do identify as a medical expert
well I do identify as a hippopotamus but
it's like no you don't we all know you
don't you're being dishonest but I
actually do identify as correct that is
my self-identity I'll put it this way
you you say that a child says I feel
this way and they should be affirmed
right
could that child be wrong right well the
child knows what's best for them so they
must so you're going to affirm what they
view is correct okay I feel that I'm
correct about this issue will you State
for the record that you affirm me in
being correct for this this issue
you're not a doctor that's basically
what they'd say right they'd immediately
ditch their premise about self-identity
is you know you could you could you
could counter with the child is talking
about their personal experience in their
life that no one else can answer for and
so my argument is are are you saying
that you know definitively the child is
right in every circumstance is it does
desistance exist right of course it does
right even if it's only they'll argue a
low rate 10 okay that means there's a 10
10 uh one in ten kids you talk to is
actually wrong but you're telling them
that they're right now why would you do
that okay maybe on the ten percent of
people you've talked to who is wrong but
please just tell me I'm right like you
would for them of course and you say it
for the camera I don't even know where
they get this idea that only an
individual can know his ontological
nature I mean that's not the case you
know I don't I I'm not a a tree expert
but I can I can look I know what a pine
tree is right it's back to the
conversation that the society is not
about the individual it's about
connection between two or more people
and if that's how the kid learns to
identify us through its surroundings and
the people yeah that's a great Point
actually let's let's read more we got uh
Shane man he says Luke my man you're
wrong the NBC reporter who doesn't do
weather showed up on the TV this morning
in the ice cold storm they had him
reporting outside during the blizzard he
looked miserable did they bring him back
he came back today really is it I I
don't know well they kept him outside
right I mean it's still not great what's
it like yeah uh I can't remember the
guys I just the last I saw he was
posting pictures from his vacation but
not at work so if he came back to work
today I apologize and I was wrong also
Keith Oberman was just banned from
Twitter jeez what yes dude Elon what
you're going too far brother you gotta
let go I know that yeah
right right you cannot that's why you
don't want one person in charge of who
gets to stay in the west to go because
if they get emotionally charged up
they're not making decisions clearly but
if it's got to be one must be going
crazy to be honest I have not seen what
they got banned for Elon so if I'm out
of line I'm out of line but come on
brother if if Elon Musk
nuke's Twitter and just shuts the whole
thing down I am going to spend I I'm
going to order every Pizza that Papa
John's has we are going to have a big
party I'm getting light set up yeah and
we are going to celebrate I love and
hate Twitter and if it finally ended I
would have a it would be like yeah I get
it I like the instant news feed but it
would just be so epically hilarious we
having pizza and wings I would lead his
cause for canonization he would do so
much good for the world
Keith olberman you know what it is these
people have been calling for violence
they've been doxing and they've been
getting away with it forever yeah this
wow great that's great you know look
they they ban Alex Jones Keith olberman
is at least as wild and eccentric and
crazy on the left as Alex Jones is on
the right he's way more crazy I know
what he's doing
and this is about the philosopher king
he's getting rid of extremists he
doesn't care what the rules are he's
saying Oberman is a nut job he posts
vitriolic Psychopathic content gone yeah
rupar he lies non-stop making everything
worse gone the problem is Keith is gonna
do that whether he's on Twitter or not
it's the same problem just muting these
people is not the answer in my opinion
man I I agree however that's what I
think Elon is doing he's saying the most
vitriolic people yeah are gone and this
means I'm willing to bet there are
people on the right he brought back
we'll probably be gone soon as well some
already are right exactly Baked Alaska I
think that he had banned instantly he
came back and was instantly saying
something about Jewish people yeah did
he get banned I think I read that he
said here's a fresh start here's your
opportunity and the vitriolic comments
are getting removed yeah so yeah it's
just cultivating uh social space I mean
you know and so I recognize I mean I
keep pushing back on You Luke because
you know I'm the tratty here but like I
recognize that there is a risk to all
these things and that's that that's why
we need to take care and I think deal
with with uh some complexity and Nuance
in our political issues
I could be wrong about making Alaska by
the way but I but I like cultivating
nice space I like living in a good
Society you know I just like it I don't
want to live in an ugly one but if
you're going to be bound down to the
powers that are in charge right now
you're bowing down to some really bad
people making some really bad decisions
Elon Muskie might agree with his
decision I personally don't uh and I
think there's a slippery slope
especially when you start centering uh
people I agree but you know I gotta uh
if oh I see what olberman Tweet someone
said this in chat alberman tweeted
Mastodon account that was tracking
elon's plane that's probably what he's
doing he's like dude my kid was attacked
I'm not playing again and those other
journalists probably are doing the same
thing yep yeah totally yep we don't know
yet we're gonna find out and I think
elon's gonna speak on this like he
speaks about a lot of his decisions and
I think he's going to be more
forthcoming about why this decision was
made I posted a tweet that people said
was making fun of Elon Musk it was
making fun of the circumstances around
him but Elon responded with fire emojis
and a lot of people said he doesn't get
it he's been made fun of and I'm like no
I think he he gets the joke yeah he
understands the point he thinks the
billionaire genius gets the meme
generally speaking you know he has said
that he wants to piss off the far left
and the far right and he wants there to
be a space so if I make a point and he's
like yeah Fair Point you know people
will blindly agree and he puts fire
emojis or maybe he's dumb whatever you
want to think like I think he he wants a
space where the the streamy you know
Kathy Griffin types are not dominating
the conversation yeah but ultimately
they're posting his location let's also
not forget I mean I know that sometimes
My Views are viewed as slightly to the
right of Genghis Khan or something
moderation is a virtue I'm not saying
that we need to squish and find some
middle ground with demons you know and
it's like like Balenciaga satanic pedos
but like you know moderation actually uh
actually being a temperate moderate
person that is a virtue let's read this
John Bushnell says on the subject of
free speech I'm more with Luke but the
bigger issue I see is that Media
Services do not give me adequate tools
to filter out content I don't want to
see especially for my kids but also just
for myself
yep that most social media networks
deeply desperately need an ability for
you to type in what you want not to see
as well as what you're searching for
yeah the real Hydro PX you know we're a
big fan Hydro he says New York City is a
duty to retreat state that means you
cannot just end someone because you
thought they were trying to harm you and
uh I disagree with that
I think there should be some reasonable
expert like you you better prove that
this person was really a threat to you
you can't just you know I was talking to
a lawyer about West Virginia or you know
someone in law enforcement and they were
like look someone walks on your property
you can't shoot them someone walks into
your property carrying a weapon now
they're in trouble even because it's an
open it's a constitutional carry state
but you trespass and you're armed and
someone fires on you you're gonna have a
very hard time defending yourself what
made you die what about a baseball bat
even even then what about a big stick
they're walking around with a stick in
their hand see this is the point of
judges and juries because the law can
say don't carry a weapon and someone
could carry a handful of nails and be
running and you and you go ah they're
coming at me and you shoot them and then
it turns out he was running to his
friend whose car broke and he had the
nails he was asking for for some reason
or something like you know it's on this
very point the wonderful Harvard law
professor Adrian vermeul has done a lot
he's trying to revive the classical law
tradition and he distinguishes between
two types of law you know in in English
we don't really distinguish but between
these things but there's law like Lex
you know law written down in statutes
and constitutions and there's law as in
use as in the the background principles
and and context in which the written
positive law exists that's very
important to know those that distinction
we talk about it from time to time
there's a funny book called like uh old
laws or something like that and it's
like it's illegal to put a pie on your
windowsill uh except on like Tuesday
afternoon and it was a law firm back
when 100 people lived in this town and
the smell of pie would attract wild
animals made sense now that it's a big
city no one worries about it and they're
like I can't put a pie in my window so
that's so weird so we don't enforce the
law anymore it's just another example of
big government taking away the simple
joy of putting a pie on my window so you
know but back then if you did people
would shop to your house they'd flip the
pie and be like are you not so we don't
want to deal with mountain lions and
they'd be offended and angry by it
nowadays nobody cares so the cop's not
going to do anything yeah
all right let's see we got here
drelo says I love you luke but your view
early on reminded me of the libertarian
version of quote well that's not real
communism yeah that's the problem
I think I want to make sure that you
don't over compensate and had soap just
pushed back so hard against
authoritarianism that you end up
becoming an a radical uh libertarian
because you're not I'm like let me just
say I'm actually glad that Luke is
pushing so hard because we don't have
that degree of Anarchy and so if you
have someone who's like no government
you end up with a little bit but when
you have a pendulum swinging if you can
push it if you push back against the
pendulum really hard you find it goes to
the extreme you want to be friction in
the system that slows the pendulum down
I don't know what you're talking about
here I made this statement before
clearly if you believe in a parks
department you're a communist listen I
cannot stand government some of the
worst horrible atrocities on the face of
this Earth democide if you don't know
what it is look it up have happened
because of government government is the
ultimate Evil we should be financing and
fueling it the decisions for your life
should be made by you and you only and
you should be making them responsibly
let Darwin win and I'm pretty sure that
government was a leading cause of
regicide as well yeah that's that's true
yeah you know you know there is another
historical fact back though some of the
worst people on Earth ever have been
individuals did you know that whoa no
listen I studied history hold on but
this might this is a this might be
shocking but I don't know if you guys
know this Hitler was an individual hold
on no he wants to hold them for it
Stalin was actually fine which one
um Ricky Ricky yeah
yeah little known cousin Richard yeah
Stalin was five people actually he's a
communist so that makes sense
all right here's another one Eric Nelson
says Luke is 100 correct those who shut
down speech are admitting they don't
have the argument to counter the speech
they dislike
uh you know so I don't consider myself
libertarian I consider myself
libertarian-ish like I'm on the
libertarian Spectrum but there's degrees
of authority you're willing to entertain
and the point that I was making with why
we don't tolerate we don't tolerate
advocacy for like he's mentioned child
porn we don't go out and arrest someone
for arguing for it though we just don't
tolerate them in our circles culturally
and it's because I I when the Florida
bill came out about parental rights and
education
and the parents right to decide if their
kid does or doesn't get medical
treatment I said makes sense the parent
should have final say then I read
another story where a parent was trying
to give their kid a sex change and
people were saying the government should
stop this and I was like now that's
interesting at what point do we decide
the government should or shouldn't it is
a it is a communal moral standard that
is different between the left and the
right the law doesn't Define so then I
was like okay we need communally agreed
upon standards
otherwise there's there's no law and
it's just and we and we will have them I
mean I guess that is my other point
regardless of what one wishes you know
would that it were so simple
there will always be Community standards
that's just how humans operate and so
yeah just less Mafia is the better for
me every everybody is like saying they
agree with Luke or they disagree I think
it's funny because no one's actually
addressing your points they're like
Lucas wrong or Luke is right instead of
Michael knows is right or wrong because
because I'm just speaking common sense
but this is a good one Diaz says Luke is
Neo dodging those questions at
point-blank range hey those were
emotionally driven questions based on a
lot of times straw man so okay if you
know excuse me for not engaging in I was
just trying to engage in the free
Marketplace of ideas of course yeah yeah
but I'm just calling them out as
emotionally driven questions
what does that mean to say an
emotionally driven question you picked
up specific circumstances with specific
very nuanced cases in order to make your
articles based on emotions rather than I
don't think my examples were nuanced at
all they were specifically not nuanced
to get you to admit that objective you
told me if I wanted to kick a baby right
because because you said that honestly I
don't want to kick a baby
then you're contradicting your previous
claim that good and bad are simply
arbitrary instead of objectively I'm
saying it's arbitrary in the human uh
perspective for one individual to decide
but you just said it subjectively it's
objectively better to bake the pie for
the Widow than to kick you contradict it
I can give you a simple physical logical
statement about what what good and bad
are there's a reason why it is
universally morally true that kicking a
baby is wrong if everybody agreed that
they could kick babies Humanity would
cease to exist we as humans exist for
The Human Experience Jeremy boring said
this and it's a brilliant Point without
humans what's the point of anything that
we do we do it for humans we have to be
good stewards of the earth that's a
reason but it's not I don't think that's
the ultimate purpose of humanity well to
to live for the like his point um I
thought it was a good point but it was
basically like if there were no humans
would anything related to humans matter
of course not like would our laws matter
no of course not so that means
everything is confined within this space
But ultimately my point is if we
tolerated things that destroyed Humanity
there would be no Humanity therefore
that is a universal bad but we don't we
don't only serve Humanity I guess is my
point it seems to me the purpose of life
is to know God and to serve him on Earth
and to enjoy him forever in heaven and
that that's the sort of traditional view
of things and for those who are agnostic
or atheist you might be sort of laughing
at me right now but at the very least
let me use kind of new agey language you
know the purpose of life man is to find
something outside of yourself and are
merely human Endeavors and to find
something greater and a higher power and
you know and whatever bro or I don't
know so but it's like I think most
people would agree with that we're not
merely serving our own interests
few decades how a lot of people have
been replacing God and using the state
as their own religion as their own kind
of cult I do believe in the power of
religion but but uh when the government
uh intervenes in so much in our lives
people are literally seeing government
as their entity as their God is what
they should worship of what they should
follow but all human conflict ultimately
is theological so all political debates
are religious as well
who's got the water yes we're about to
go to members only so let me read one
more really good Super Chat Carlo Magno
says Tim I don't believe in capital
punishment unless you trespass in my
property pool
well it's a funny it's a funny super
chat but my point is
I don't believe in killing another
person unless they're an immediate
threat the challenge however is if
there's someone who is clearly a threat
to society and you've subdued them by
putting them in a small concrete box
snuffing out their life is
is a challenge for me morally is it not
you know some people say death penalty
is cruel and unusual punishment seems to
be the opposite it's well we know it was
not unusual from the ratification of the
Constitution because the punishment for
a felony was the death penalty but don't
you think life in prison or solitary or
something to me that seems I agree cruel
and unusual I I I would actually argue
locking someone in a box if someone's
truly a threat to others so you decide
to lock him up and control every moment
of their life and limit their the
ability to live for 30 years could
actually be worse than just killing them
but I just I you know sometimes I don't
have logical answers for for things like
when I when I was talking with um Glenn
Beck about abortion I was like the issue
ultimately comes down to there's a point
where
I just don't know I just don't have it
in me to advocate for killing another
person that has been locked in a box
maybe they can request it but let's do
this we're going to go to the members
only section and have a ridiculous
debate where everyone's gonna start
yelling again so head over to
timcast.com become a member I think this
one's going to be really fun and there's
going to be a lot of noises so go to
timcast.com click the join us button
sign up and we'll be there in about an
hour you can follow the show uh you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast smash
that like button and subscribe if you
haven't already Michael do you want to
shout anything out I do actually I do
well obviously my show the Michael
Knowles show The Daily wire five days a
week I love shouting that out uh I love
shouting out the book club at prageru
that's another show that I do but
speaking of books and it's on this show
in particular do you know I
I would like to thank the Tim the Tim
cast
you guys almost single-handedly made
that book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds available now for uh
order uh you you almost
I mean I'm not sure I went on very big
TV shows and very big shows to sell the
book and they helped
nothing worked like your show Tim and
the the fanatical Tim cast monsters who
forced you to plug my book every five
times a show for like three months it
was great so thank you for making and
speechless number one you know like
because people would Super Chat and say
man that story is really crazy Tim
hearing about this family has left me
speechless just like Michael is and
after a couple times I'd be like okay
okay and then because you know here's
what I do when I read super chats I
actually read them before I speak the
words so I'm reading two words ahead of
what I'm saying but I can't read the
whole sentence before I start reading
otherwise the show would lag so I read
man that story is really crazy then I
say it and then I see the speeches and I
go and I gotta I gotta read it but it
was it was it was it was funny it was
fun and it was like a brilliant emergent
marketing campaign it worked really well
I wish I could take credit but it's
really it's just your uh fanatical
listeners it was I mean thank you thank
you memes meme makers where can people
find you on Twitter people get for now
they can find me at Michael J Knowles
but I don't know Elon is going on a
Banning spree so maybe by the end of
this maybe I'll be going to maybe yeah
did we docs You by telling people where
you were right now you might have um it
was great talking to all you Communists
today
um I didn't agree with you Michael but
don't worry I'm not a statist I'm not
going to ban you or try to get you
banned but I I thank you for engaging
with me and creating a thought-provoking
conversation that uh sparked a lot of
different conversations so it was
awesome it was fun well thank you I
enjoyed it as well and I am texting Elon
right now to ban you from all social
media platforms he follows me I got him
directly
nothing I don't know if I don't know if
you got them direct but I I got I got
the connect you don't so uh my YouTube
channel
um and my Twitter uh uh channel that
Elon follows is uh at uh Luke we are
change we are change on YouTube I did a
very interesting video about what's
happening with Twitter Elon Musk Free
Speech uh that conversation is on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
see you there thank you again so much
for having me this was really fun thank
you Michael appreciate it thank you
always spectacular Michael uh God is
good I believe the word is derived from
good God they sound like the exact I
mean I can't imagine they are not meant
for you can just be a coincidence and
let's find out let's get down to what
that means maybe later tonight uh other
than that yeah literally yeah is good
yeah just with an extra oh uh or good as
God I need a figma developer someone out
there that does UI and ux and is
familiar with the figma stuff that can
build components for figma if you want
to get involved with a non-profit that
I'm starting that we're building some
badass technology figma figma not ligma
not their 24 24 Jack's giving out
funding for these projects man oh yeah
Jack just funded Noster Jack Dorsey and
Tor uh so beautiful with uh with the you
know the the tech stuff you're building
yeah I'm really excited to get Bill
Altman involved Jack Dorsey Chris
pavlovsky I think it's gonna be a really
great front-end piece to add on to a lot
of these social networks so if you want
to get involved hit me up on Twitter or
mines and um we'll work from there and
I'm Ian Crossland obviously you can
check me out anywhere you want baby see
you later
what's up everybody thanks for having me
on guys thanks chat uh I want to shout
out Serge follow him at surge.com he's
not here today and he also wanted me to
shout out Elon ma which is Chinese Elon
Musk oh yeah he's a favorite of ours so
go check him out he's great all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in about an hour thanks for
hanging out